I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office re-watch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. That's us! Happy New Year! Yes, this is our first episode that we recorded after our two-week Christmas and holiday break. We are back, guys. We're... What? I don't know. I didn't have an end to that sentence. I did. And I was gonna say we're back. We're freezing our butts off. It's cold in here. And I just had to wait. Like,
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。我们还是好朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极版《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。那就是我们！新年快乐！没错，这是我们在两周的圣诞和节日假期后录制的首集节目。伙计们，我们回来了。我们……什么？我不知道。我那句话还没说完呢。我说了。而且我本来想说我们回来了。我们冷得屁股都要冻掉了。这里好冷。我刚刚不得不等着。就像，
felt like almost a full 10 minutes for Angela to lay all her cards on the desk. It is such a tedious process. Did you say allow all her cards on the desk? I said, lay out all. Lay out all. Lay out all? Is that St. Louis? Oh, you're just mad because of waffle ball and chunk it. Hey, you know what? People in Texas say chunk it. Here I was being like all self-conscious because you said, no, it's chuck it. Then I'm talking to my mom over the holidays. We're talking about going through the garage. And she goes, ah, just chunk it. It's a Texas thing, lady. It is. I will admit it because I came home that day and I was telling my husband Lee who
感觉快整整10分钟了，安吉拉才把她所有的底牌都亮在桌上。这真是一个乏味的过程。你刚才说把所有的底牌都允许在桌上吗？我说的是，亮出所有。亮出所有。亮出所有？那是圣路易斯的说法吗？哦，你生气只是因为“软式垒球”和“把它扔掉”。嘿，你知道吗？得州人就说“把它扔掉”。我还在这儿自我意识过剩呢，因为你之前说，不，是“把它狠狠扔掉”。然后我在假期跟我妈妈聊天。我们在讨论收拾车库的事。她说，啊，就把它扔掉吧。这是得州人的特色，女士。确实是。我承认这一点，因为那天我回到家，把“把它扔掉”这个梗，以及它把我逗得有多开心，讲给我丈夫李听。他
grew up in Texas all about the chunk it thing and how much it made me laugh. And he said to me, Jenna, I moved to Texas in middle school and I had that same conversation. Someone said, just chunk it. And I said, what chunk it? He's like, they say it. They do. It's like pop and soda. Thank you. Right. Thank you. And I guess it's sorry, Texas. Don't be sorry. Just chunk it. Um, and I guess in St. Louis, they say I'm not a liar on the table. Lay out all your card. All your card. Shall we begin? Let's begin. All right. Performance review, season two episode eight written by Larry Wilmore and directed by Paul Feig. I'm going to
在得州长到初中，他也经历过同样的对话。有人说，就把它扔掉。我说，什么叫把它扔掉？他说，他们就是这么说的。他们确实这么说。这就好比“汽水”和“苏打水”。谢谢。没错。谢谢。我想，对不起，得州。别介意。就把它扔掉吧。呃，我想在圣路易斯，他们说的是“我不是桌上的骗子”。亮出你所有的牌。你所有的牌。我们开始吧？我们开始吧。好的，绩效评估，第二季第八集，由拉里·威尔莫尔编剧，保罗·费格执导。我来给
give you a summary. In this episode, Michael is supposed to be conducting performance reviews of his staff, but instead he calls everyone into his office one by one to help him decipher a voicemail from Jan. Because if you remember in the previous episode, he and Jan hooked up. They did. They smooched in the parking lot, maybe played some grabby games back at her place. Yeah. And he is convinced now that they are boyfriend and girlfriend. Even though it's clear that Jan has said this is a one time thing, please make nothing of it. Michael is determined to read between the lines. Also in this episode, Pam
你们做一个总结。这一集中，迈克尔本该对员工进行绩效评估，但他却把每个人一个接一个地叫进办公室，帮他解读詹的一条语音留言。因为如果你还记得上一集的话，他和詹勾搭上了。他们确实勾搭了。他们在停车场亲热了，可能还在她家玩了一些动手动脚的游戏。是的。现在他确信他们是男女朋友了。尽管很明显詹已经说过这只是一夜情，请不要放在心上。迈克尔偏要捕风捉影。这一集中还有，帕姆
and Jim pranked Dwight by convincing him that it is Friday instead of Thursday. The end of the summary is done. Jenna, that was a fantastic summary. Thank you. Well done. Thank you so much. All right. You want Fast Fact number one? I do. Fast Fact number one. I said this is written by Larry Wilmore. Mm hmm. You guys, I hope you remember he played Mr. Brown in our diversity day episode. Yes. Larry was a writer and producer and an amazing performer. Yes. And we are going to speak with Larry today. Larry is so great. I have such fun memories of working with him. You know, he created the Bernie
和吉姆捉弄了德怀特，让他以为今天是星期五而不是星期四。总结部分结束了。珍娜，这个总结太棒了。谢谢。干得漂亮。非常感谢。好啦，你们想要趣味事实第一条吗？我想要。趣味事实第一条。我刚才说过这一集是拉里·威尔莫尔编剧的。嗯哼。伙计们，我希望你们还记得他在我们的多元化日那一集里扮演布朗先生。是的。拉里是一位编剧兼制片人，还是一位出色的表演者。是的。今天我们要和拉里聊聊。拉里太棒了。我对跟他合作有着非常美好的回忆。你知道，他创作了《伯尼·
Mac show. He has been a correspondent on the Daily Show. We've talked a little bit about this super talented guy. I'm really excited to talk to him because he was just, he's so smart and funny. I think that was one of the things about our writer's room is like how fricking smart they were. They're really smart. I think people underestimate how smart you have to be to be a great writer. Yeah. Like they really go hand in hand. I think, I don't know. Sometimes I wonder, have we wasted all these minds? Should they be off making scientific discoveries? Because some of them were some of just like the most brilliant people I've
麦克秀》。他曾担任过《每日秀》的记者。我们之前稍微聊过这个超级有才华的家伙。我真的很兴奋能和他谈谈，因为他太聪明太搞笑了。我觉得我们的编剧室的一个特点就是他们聪明得要命。他们真的很聪明。我觉得人们低估了成为一名伟大的作家需要多么聪明。是的。这两者真的是相辅相成的。我觉得，我不知道。有时我在想，我们是不是浪费了所有这些头脑？他们是不是应该去做出科学发现？因为他们中的一些人是我见过的最聪明的人，
ever met and they're just sitting writing great jokes. But then without them we wouldn't have the fitness orb. Fast Fact number two. I was really sick in this episode. You were so sick. Do you remember that? Not only do I remember that you were sick, but I wrote down a quote that I read online. It says, where did you read this? On Wikipedia, on the office performance review, Wikipedia. It says, Jenna Fisher came down with a cold. Instead of postponing, however, Fisher memorized and performed all her lines, resulting in fellow cast member Angela Kinsey calling her a trooper. You were in this episode because you were really,
而他们却只是坐在那儿写出色的笑话。但如果没有他们，我们就不会有健身球了。趣味事实第二条。我在这一集里病得很重。你病得太厉害了。你还记得吗？我不仅记得你生病了，我还记下了一段我在网上看到的引述。上面写着，你在哪儿看到的？在维基百科上，关于《办公室》绩效评估的维基百科。上面写着，珍娜·费舍患了感冒。然而，费舍并没有推迟拍摄，而是背熟并表演了所有台词，导致同剧演员安吉拉·金西称赞她是个硬汉。你出演了这一集，因为你真的、
really sick. But that's one thing I think you guys, I don't know if you guys know this, but when you're on a set and you get sick, you don't go home. No. They literally prop you up because so many people, like what, 300 people their whole day revolves around that day's filming. Yeah. And so it's... They can't shut down the filming just because you don't feel good. Yeah. So a doctor will show up, give you a shot and you stay at work. Oh yeah. I mean, I've seen them tape people. They're like, oh, have you stopped vomiting for 30 minutes? Let's get you on set and see what we can grab. Oh yeah. Like that happens. So I was really sick.
真的很生病。但我觉得有一件事，我不知道你们知不知道，当你在片场生病时，你是不能回家的。对。他们甚至会把你撑起来，因为有那么多人，大概有300人，他们整天的工作都围绕着当天的拍摄转。是的。所以……他们不能仅仅因为你感觉不好就停工。是的。所以医生会赶来，给你打一针，然后你继续留下来工作。哦，对。我的意思是，我见过他们用胶带固定演员。他们会问，哦，你已经30分钟没吐了吗？我们快让你上片场看看能拍到什么吧。哦，对。这种事确实会发生。所以我当时病得很重。
This is my first time ever having to perform this ill. I took tons of pseudofed. I had a sinus infection. You were a little loopy. I was super loopy. Here's what's crazy. At the end of the week, Greg Daniels called my manager about my performance in this episode. And my manager called me. I get this message, Jenna, please call me. Greg Daniels has called about your performance in this week's episode and I want to speak with you about it. Shataki mushrooms. I thought I was being fired. Yeah. I thought, oh my gosh, this is it. That's it. I don't know why. Did you... I, as an actor, especially in the early
这是我第一次病得这么重还要演戏。我吃了大量的伪麻黄碱。我得了鼻窦炎。你有点神志不清。我超级神志不清。疯狂的是什么呢？周末的时候，格雷格·丹尼尔斯就我在这一集的表现给我的经纪人打了电话。我的经纪人给我打了电话。我接到这个消息，珍娜，请给我回电话。格雷格·丹尼尔斯打电话来谈你这一集的表现，我想跟你聊聊这个。香菇。我还以为我要被炒了。对。我想，哦天哪，就是这样。就这样了。我不知道为什么。你……我，作为一个演员，尤其是在早期
days and on early shows, I always felt like I could be fired in any moment. Oh, me and Brian and Oscar were always like, accounting's totally replaceable. You could be fired at any time. Well, that's not true. But yes, that you have this feeling like I'm failing constantly. Yeah. So my manager says, Jenna, we got this phone call and she got all my agents on the phone too, which you're like, oh my gosh, they only do that if it's great news or horrible news. Or really bad news. Yeah. Yeah. So I'm like, and she's like, we received a phone call from Greg Daniels because he wanted all of us to know how outstanding you were in this episode, that
和早期剧集里，我总觉得我随时都可能被炒。哦，我和布兰恩还有奥斯卡总觉得，会计部门完全是可替代的。你随时都可能被炒。好吧，这不是真的。但确实，你会有一种我一直在失败的感觉。是的。所以我的经纪人说，珍娜，我们接到了这个电话，她把我的所有经纪人都拉进群通话了，你会觉得，哦天哪，他们只有在听到好消息或特大噩耗时才会这么做。或者真的很糟糕的消息。对。对。所以我心里想，她说，我们接到了格雷格·丹尼尔斯的电话，因为他想让我们所有人都知道你在这一集里表现得多么出色，
it was some of your best work. And to please say whatever it is you did to prepare for this episode, keep it up. Take Sudafed. I was like, well, I don't know what to do with this compliment. Clearly, I'm a fantastic actress on Sudafed. Yeah. Well, okay. Okay. Should I move on to fast fact number three? Yes. All right. Fast fact number three is also a belated fast fact. I realize I missed something a couple of episodes back in the fight. What? Which applies to all the episodes moving forward, talking about cold opens. Do you want to tell folks what a cold open is? Yes. So in a script, scripts usually have like a three act structure
这堪称你最好的作品之一。并且请你保持为这一集做准备的任何状态，继续保持。吃伪麻黄碱。我当时想，好吧，我不知道该怎么接受这个赞美。显然，我是一个靠伪麻黄碱支撑的超级巨星演员。对。好吧，好吧。我应该进入趣味事实第三条吗？好的。好的，趣味事实第三条也是一个迟来的趣味事实。我意识到我漏掉了前面几集打斗中的某个内容。什么？这适用于后面所有的剧集，也就是关于冷开场。你想告诉大家什么是冷开场吗？好的。所以在一个剧本中，剧本通常有三幕结构，
where you tell the story, right? And like a little mini three acts. Yeah. Well, we started doing this thing that we called the cold open and it's before the credits and it's a little joke or almost like a standalone moment that might apply later to the episode, but also might not. Might not. It's just like its own little moment. So that was something that our show did. We had these little cold opens and then we're also going to start adding tags soon. Oh, tags are fun. Tags were at the end. At the very end. We would come back from a commercial break and you'd get like a seven second tag. They were very short. Really short. Another
你讲述故事，对吧？就像几个迷你三幕一样。是的。嗯，我们开始做一件事，我们称之为冷开场，它在片头字幕之前，是一个小笑话，或者说几乎是一个独立的情节，可能在后面剧集中会有用，但也可能不会。可能不会。它就像是它自己的一个小片段。所以这是我们节目的一大特色。我们有这些小冷开场，然后我们很快也要开始加标签了。哦，标签很有趣。标签在结尾。在最后。我们从商业广告插播回来，你会看到一个大约七秒钟的标签。它们非常短。非常短。又一个
little joke. Yeah. They were always really short, like maybe just one page, three lines, just something really tiny. Yes. In this episode, we have a cold open that is one of our most famous cold opens, the fitness orb. Yes. Which is so great and we had a ton of fan questions about this. Probably our most frequently asked moment. About this episode for sure. Definitely. For example, Fernanda Fuentes and Derek Ford both asked, how many times did you have to film the cold open with Dwight's fitness ball? And David Nicholas asked, how many fitness orbs did you go through before it popped just right? Well, everyone, it was not meant to
小笑话。是的。它们总是非常短，可能只有一页、三行，就是一些非常微小的内容。是的。在这一集中，我们的冷开场是最著名的冷开场之一——健身球。是的。这个太棒了，我们收到了大量关于这个的粉丝提问。这可能是我们被问到频率最高的一个时刻。绝对是关于这一集的。肯定的。例如，费尔南达·富恩特斯和德里克·福德都问，拍摄德怀特的健身球那个冷开场，你们拍了多少次？大卫·尼古拉斯问，在它刚好爆掉之前，你们用坏了多少个健身球？好吧，各位，它本来不是要
pop. Oh, first of all, Jenna, you look really excited. Are you sitting on some info? I'm sitting on some info. I traded messages with Phil Shea. Phil Shea props master. Yes. He told me all about the fitness orbs. So first of all, he bought 17. 17 fitness orbs. Yes. And he practiced with John using three of them. Phil Shea sat on them and John, like, hit them. Yes. Phil Shea was, talk about a trooper, Phil Shea. He's amazing. So the idea was that John would stick the scissors into the fitness orb and it would deflate very slowly. And the camera would be in front of Dwight's desk and you would just see him very slowly melt
爆掉的。哦，首先，珍娜，你看起来很兴奋。你是不是掌握了什么内幕？我是掌握了一些内幕。我和菲尔·谢伊互发了信息。菲尔·谢伊，道具师。是的。他把关于健身球的一切都告诉我了。首先，他买了我17个。17个健身球。是的。他和约翰一起用其中3个做了练习。菲尔·谢伊坐在上面，而约翰就像是，打它们。是的。菲尔·谢伊——说到硬汉，非菲尔·谢伊莫属。他太棒了。所以原本的想法是，约翰会把剪刀扎进健身球里，然后它会非常缓慢地放气。摄像机会在德怀特办公桌的正前方，你会看到他非常缓慢地融化
to the floor as Jim, very smugly. Looks on. Yes. That was what was in the script. So they practiced three times. It worked perfectly. And they had 14 left for the scene. And Phil said to John, as long as you don't hit the seam of the ball with the scissors, which would be like a one in million chance that you could do it, the ball will slowly deflate and it will work as planned. So it's also very hard to see the seam. Oh, yeah. Yeah. I mean, yeah, you would have to hit it just right. Yes. It would be basically impossible to do. Yeah. So they did 13 takes and it worked just right and everyone was happy and they were about to move on. And Phil
到地板上，而吉姆则是一副沾沾自喜的样子。在一旁看着。是的。剧本里原本是这样的。所以他们练习了三次。效果完美。他们还剩下14个给这场戏用。菲尔对约翰说，只要你不用剪刀扎到球的接缝处，球有一百万分之一的几率会被扎破，只要不扎到接缝，球就会慢慢放气，按计划进行。所以接缝其实也很难看到。哦，对。对。我的意思是，是的，你必须刚好扎中那个地方。是的。这基本上是不可能的任务。对。所以他们拍了13条，效果刚刚好，大家都很高兴，正准备进入下一场。然后菲尔
said, I have one more ball. Yeah. So Paul Feek said, Oh, what the heck? Let's just do one more. And in all the 13 takes, you guys, rain as Dwight slowly sunk to the ground like, yeah, right. And it was perfect. So they have an extra ball. They're like, just, we'll just do one more. Let's do it. On that last take, John hit the seam by accident. And you can see the shock on rain space when it exploded and he fell to the floor. We were all completely shocked. We were like, Oh my God. And you can totally see John break. You can see his shoulders and he, he very quickly. Oh, he's such a pro. He turns his back and he like dies out of
说，我还有一个球。是的。于是保罗·费格说，管它的呢？我们再拍一条吧。在前13条里，伙计们，雷恩饰演的德怀特慢慢沉向地面，就像，耶，对。而且完美无缺。所以他们多出了一个球。他们想，好吧，我们就再拍一个。开始吧。就在最后那条里，约翰不小心扎到了接缝。当它爆炸时，你可以看到雷恩脸上的震惊表情，他摔倒在地板上。我们当时都彻底惊呆了。我们当时想，哦天哪！而且你完全能看到约翰笑场了。你能看到他的肩膀，然后他迅速地——哦，他真是个专业演员。他转过身去，直接退出了
the scene. He just like leaves. Phyllis was really surprised too. I swear you can hear somebody say, what? Like either John or rain is like, what is happening? And they were going to cut that out. They were like, Oh my gosh, we're so sorry rain, are you all right? We were laughing so hard. And when they went in to edit the episode, they put in what was scripted. They put in the slow deflate. And it was Larry Wilmore, the writer. Yes. Who said, you have to put the blooper one in. You have to put the fast pop in. Yeah, he fought for that. He fought for that. And he was right. That is an amazing moment. That is an example of just a perfect
片场。他就像是直接离开了。菲莉丝也大吃一惊。我发誓你能听到有人说，什么？就像约翰或雷恩在说，这是怎么回事？他们本来打算把这个剪掉的。他们当时想，哦天哪，雷恩，真是对不起，你没事吧？我们当时笑得太厉害了。等他们去剪辑这一集时，他们放进了按剧本拍的内容。他们放进了缓慢放气的版本。是编剧拉里·威尔莫尔。是的。他提出，必须把花絮的那条放进去。你必须把快速爆炸的那条放进去。是的，他为此据理力争。他为之据理力争。他是对的。那真是一个令人惊叹的时刻。那简直就是一个完美的
cold open. And now I think we should take a little break and we'll come back with our interview with Larry. Yes, we're going to come back and talk to Larry Wilmore, writer of this episode. All right, Sam, let's give Larry a call. Yeah, let's call him up. Hey, it's so nice to hear you guys. Oh my gosh, same. We're so happy this worked out. Congrats on the pod, guys. What a great idea too. Oh, we're loving it. I mean, you know, Larry, we're just too chatty BFFs that get to talk about our favorite job ever. From the beginning, from the beginning. Okay, well, Larry, thank you so much for joining us. Do you know you are our first writer as a
冷开场的范例。现在我觉得我们应该休息一下，回来后播放对拉里的采访。是的，我们要回来和这集的编剧拉里·威尔莫尔聊聊。好的，萨姆，我们给拉里打个电话吧。对，我们给他打个电话。嘿，听到你们的声音真好。哦天哪，我也是。我们很高兴这能成行。恭喜你们开播客，伙计们。真是个绝妙的主意。哦，我们太喜欢了。我的意思是，你知道的，拉里，我们只是两个爱唠嗑的闺蜜，有机会谈论我们有史以来最喜欢的工作。从一开始，从一开始。好吧，拉里，非常感谢你加入我们。你知道你是我们迎来的第一位编剧嘉宾吗？
guest? Wow. And so one of the questions we're asking everyone that comes on is, how did it come about that you became part of the office? God, I have so many fond memories of that time. Mine is a little bit more complicated, I guess, than everybody else. I had just started to deal with NBC at that time. I had just done the Bernie Mac Show and I knew Greg from before. I had done a show called the PJs and he was on King of the Hill and we used to see each other all the time and Greg was a buddy of mine and he was, he had never done a single camera show before and NBC wanted to know if I wanted to consult on that while I was
哇。所以我们问每位嘉宾的一个问题是，你是怎么加入《办公室》的？天哪，我对那段时光有那么多美好的回忆。我的经历可能比其他所有人都要稍微复杂一点。当时我刚开始和NBC合作。我刚做完《伯尼·马克秀》，而且我之前就认识格雷格。我曾做过一部叫《PJs》的节目，而他在《山丘之王》工作，我们过去常常经常见面。格雷格是我的好朋友，而且他以前从未做过单镜头情景喜剧，NBC想知道我是否愿意在开发期间去担任顾问，你知道的，只是去充当另一个声音。你知道，我当然觉得这很棒，因为我其实几年前就看过《英国办公室》，当时我去英国参加情景喜剧研讨会之类的活动，大家都在放映情景喜剧，而我当时在放映《伯尼·马克秀》的试播集，而阿什·阿塔洛，他是原版《办公室》的制片人，当时在放映《办公室》的喜剧救济集，我想，也就是他们穿着租来的服装那一集。
developing, you know, just to be another voice in there. You know, of course, I thought it was great because I had actually seen the office years before when I went to England to do the sitcom seminar type thing or whatever and people were screening the sitcoms and I was screening the pilot of the Bernie Mac Show and Ash Attalo, who was a producer in the original office, was screening the comic relief episode, I think, of the office, the one where they wear the rent, knows it's them. Yeah. And I had never seen the office before and it was great, of course, you know, and we were all like congratulating each other
是的。我以前从未看过《英国办公室》，当然，它太棒了，你知道的，我们当时都在互相祝贺，我记得他走到我面前对我说，拉里，你能答应我一件事吗？我说，当然，他说，请不要让他们把这个带到美国去毁了它。我说，当然不会。我说，顺便说一句，如果它真的去了美国，我也不会跟它有任何瓜葛。我正在参与美版《办公室》的工作，一开始这挺有趣的，这是一件事，我不知道你们是否意识到，在开始的时候，关于我们的剧，演艺圈里有很多负面声音。我们有点与世隔绝，因为还记得吗，我们在洛杉矶市中心那个旧仓库里拍摄前
afterwards and I remember he came to me and said, Larry, can you promise me one thing? I said, sure, he says, please don't let them take this to America and ruin it. I go, of course not. I said, by the way, if it ever goes to America, I won't have anything to do with it. I'm working on the American version of the office and it's funny in the beginning, this is something, I don't know if you guys, how much you realize in the beginning of what was going on, that there was a lot of negativity in showbiz about our show. We were kind of sequestered from it because remember, we were shooting in that old warehouse in mid LA, that first
五集的时候，你知道的，人们以为我们会毁了《办公室》，比如我会跟城里的编剧们聊天，他们对此态度真的很冷嘲热讽。他们会说，那你现在在做什么？我说，哦，我在做《办公室》，好吧，我就像，什么？这很好，伙计们，这会很好的。而格雷格，正如你们所知，太卓越了。我觉得格雷格·弗洛比对待它的态度就好像我们要被停播了一样，你知道的，所以，你知道，把自己逼入绝境，特别是帕姆和吉姆以及所有那些乱七八糟的事，然后，你知道的，尽可能多地享受乐趣。所以编剧室里有一种非常棒的感觉，
five episodes, you know, and people thought we were gonna ruin the office, like I would talk to writers around town and they were real snidey about it. They said, so what are you working on? I said, oh, I'm working on the office, okay, I'm like, what? It's good, guys, it's gonna be good. And Greg, you know, as you guys know, so brilliant. I feel Greg Floppey was just righted as if we're gonna go off the air, you know, so, you know, write ourselves in the corner, especially with Pam and Jim and all that kind of stuff and just, you know, just have as much fun as possible. So there was such a great feeling in the writer's room that
觉得我们可以随心所欲地做任何事，因为，你知道，谁在乎呢？我们可能随时会被停播。我的意思是，我们放手一搏吧。这是一个多么深刻的见解，因为我当时也有同感。我觉得我们仿佛是在一个泡沫里制作这部剧，有时候纯粹是为了自娱自乐。还记得我们刚开始时的剧本围读吗？我们甚至不是围着桌子坐的。我们当时就直接坐在片场。我们把办公桌椅拉过来，围成一个圈。然后在那段拍摄间歇期，我去客串了一把，参加了他们的剧本围读，那可真是一件大事。有一张大桌子，每个人都围着它坐，你面前还有一个写着你名字的小铭牌，
we could just do whatever we wanted because, you know, who cared? We might be off the air. I mean, we'll just go for it. That's such a good insight because I felt that way too. I felt like we were making the show in a bubble or making it for our own amusement sometimes. Do you remember our table reads in the beginning? They weren't around a table. We would just sit on the set. We'd all pull up our desk chairs and we'd sit in a circle. And then during our hiatus, I did a guest star and I went in for the table read and it was like a big deal. There was a big table and everyone sat around it and you had like a little placard with
你的台词还被荧光笔高亮了，现场还有电视台的高层。我只记得《办公室》的第一季，我们真的就像是孤军奋战。感觉就是这样。是的，我们就像是那辆“小火车头”。编剧室里是什么情况？《办公室》编剧室的运作方式，特别是在早期，就是我们有什么想法就会写在一张小索引卡上，然后贴在墙上。你知道，过了一会儿，墙上贴满了各种想法，都是关于会发生什么的好玩的喜剧点子。在很多情况下，
your name and, and like your lines had been highlighted and there was network people there. And I just remember that first season of the office, we really were just sort of like on our own. It felt like. Yeah, we were the little engine that could. What was it like in the, in the writer's room? The way the writer's room went on the office, especially in the early days was whatever idea we had would go in a little index card and would be slapped on the wall. You know, after a while we had all these ideas that were just slapped on the wall that were just really funny comic ideas of what could happen. And in many instances,
我们创作一集节目的方式就是把两三张卡片拼在一起，那就会变成一集，你知道的。想法通常就是这样产生的。就是我们互相逗乐。而且顺便说一句，提出想法的人不一定非要写那一集。那是一种非常民主的方式。格雷格会把任务分派给任何人，然后你就去写那一集。所以每个人都参与了所有的剧集。你知道，尽管我们每个人都出去写了一版初稿，但在剧本定稿发出之前，我们都为那一集贡献了力量。当然，当它被改完送回来时，你知道的，那真的很有趣。
the way we created episode was we put like two or three cards together and that would be an episode, you know. And that's how ideas were generally generated. Us just making each other laugh. And whoever came up with the idea didn't necessarily write the show, by the way. It was very democratic in that way. Greg would just hand it out to whoever and you would just write that episode. So everybody had a hand in all the episodes. You know, even though we each went out and wrote a draft, we all contributed to the episode before it went out. Of course, when it came back in, you know, and that was a lot of fun.
我唯一的遗憾是在第二季时，我想出了那个万圣节剧集的点子，我真的很想亲自写那一集，结果我想：啊！没能写成让我觉得好遗憾，但你知道的，你根本不在乎。你很快就释怀了。那依然很有趣。但那个点子，只是因为我当时觉得，如果迈克尔必须在大家穿着化装服的时候解雇某个人，那一定会非常搞笑。它就是源于这样一个简单的笑话，你知道的，就像如果在万圣节解雇某人会怎样。而你是对的！剧集通常就是这样开始的，源于这样一个核心笑话，然后将其扩展成整整一集。我们非常喜欢你在《多元化日》里的表演。我的意思是，
My one regret was in the second season, I came up with that Halloween episode idea and I really wanted to write that when I was like, nah! I was so salty that I didn't get to write it, but you know, you didn't care. You got over it. It was still fun. But that idea just, just from me thinking it would be very funny if Michael had to fire somebody while they were in costume. It just came from that simple joke, you know, like if you fire somebody during Halloween. And you're right! And that's usually how episodes just started from just a central joke like that and it would expand out to an episode. We so enjoyed your performance in Diversity Day. I mean,
我们知道你是一名编剧。我们知道你是我们的，你知道的，我们的编剧兼制片人。但当你真正参与表演时，你表现得太棒了，这让我对你有了全新的欣赏。我记得在拍摄时就觉得你太惊艳了，但后来看到成片时，你把布朗先生演得太完美了。哦，谢谢你，安吉拉。你太好了。我和肯也有一段交情。他执导了《伯尼·马克秀》的试播集，我非常了解肯。肯·奎帕斯，也就是导演。当时，我的职业生涯正经历一次转型。我，我邪恶的计划一直是为自己创作一部剧。我以表演开启了我的职业生涯，同时我还做过单口喜剧演员和演员等等，
we knew you as a writer. We knew you as our, you know, our writer, producer. But then when you got to perform, you were so fantastic and then I had just such a new appreciation for it. I remember thinking you were amazing when we were filming it, but then watching it, it, it, you were so perfect as Mr. Brown. Oh, thank you, Angela. So nice of you. Ken, I had a relationship with as well. He directed the pilot of the Bernie Mac show and I knew Ken very well. Ken Quapas, who was the director. And at the time, I was kind of going through a transition in my career. I, my evil plan had always been to create a show for myself. I would start
后来我开始在电视界从事编剧和制片工作，因为我觉得好莱坞当时找不到我的定位。对我来说，为自己开辟一片天地是更好的选择。我所做的喜剧风格只是稍微有点不同。一旦我开始从事编剧和制片，我真的很享受这个过程。在经历了《伯尼·马克秀》的那场闹剧之后，我想，好吧，现在也许是时候开始考虑换个档位了。当我在《办公室》剧组时，我记得我好像在围读时读过那个角色，但我本来并不打算去演它，因为我当时实在太忙了。而且我坚信，你知道的，我们应该雇佣演员，给演员一个尝试的机会。尽管格雷格对这部剧的理念是他真的希望编剧们也参与表演，这真的很棒。而且，你知道的，像敏迪、BJ，甚至保罗·利伯斯坦——顺便说一句，他还是我当年在《伯尼·马克秀》里雇用的。我当时根本不知道保罗说他擅长演戏。我要是知道，当初就会在我的节目里雇用他了。他太棒了。这给节目带来了一种非常有趣的氛围，你知道的，让编剧成为其中一部分，并且让那些原本只是背景板的人，比如安吉拉，你们在拍摄时开始加入一些即兴发挥。
at my career as a performer as well as to stand up in an actor and all that kind of stuff. And I started writing and producing in television because I felt like Hollywood couldn't find me. It was better for me to create a space for myself. I was just the kind of comedy that I did. It was just a little different. And I really enjoyed writing and producing once I started doing it. And after the whole Bernie Mac show debacle, I thought, well, now it may be time to start thinking about this other gear. And when I was on the office, I remember reading, I think I read that part at the table, but I didn't have an intention of
你们让这些角色变得活灵活现的方式，尽管一开始并没有太多素材，但真的很棒。你知道的，甚至只是你们给出的眼神以及所有那些细节，都赋予了这部剧一种非常本真的感觉，你知道的。但在最初，我真的不想演那个角色。肯有点说服了我，你知道的，我当时根本没考虑这事儿。我只是觉得，是的，我们应该找个演员来演。但后来我意识到，这正是我们在剧中所做的，我们所有人都在为这件作品添砖加瓦。所以一旦我接受了这一点，我最终发现这其实
playing it just because I was real busy. And I really believe that, you know, we should hire actors, give actors a shot to do this. Even though Greg's philosophy on the show was he really wanted the writers to perform too, which was really fantastic. And, you know, people like Mindy and BJ and even Paul Lieberstein, who by the way, I had hired on the Bernie Mac show. I had no idea Paul said, good to be an actor. I would have hired him on my show. He was so great. And it gave it such an interesting feel, you know, to have writers being a part of it and to have, you know, people who were in the background, like Angela, some of
非常有趣。顺便说一句，我还保留了一些当时的废镜头。正如你们所记得的那样，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔在模仿克里斯·洛克的时候简直太搞笑了。我当时真的是笑得眼泪都流出来了。我们今天可能甚至都没法拍那一集了，你知道的，因为从那么多光荣的方面来看，它都太不合时宜了，你知道的。人们会走过来叫你布朗先生吗？随时随地。这太疯狂了。人们会说，比如，我在人们心中有各种各样不同的身份，有些人从《深夜秀》、《每日秀》认识我。有些人只是通过《办公室》和那个角色认识我，
the ad libs you guys started doing in the life. The way you guys brought those characters to life, but not really a lot of material in the beginning was fantastic. You know, just even the looks you guys gave and all that stuff really gave this organic feel to it, you know. But in the beginning, I really didn't want to play that part. And Ken kind of talks me into, you know, just, I just wasn't thinking about it. I just thought, yeah, we should be bringing an actress. But then I realized that's kind of what we're doing on the show is we're all kind of like pitching into this thing. So once I embraced it, I just ended up just having
以及通过我做的其他事情。但这真的很神奇。他们不叫我拉里·威尔莫尔，他们叫我布朗先生。就是这样。这就是我在他们心目中的形象。这永远不会改变。但我认为这是一种荣誉。你想想，伙计们，你有多少次机会能扮演这样一个角色——我在银幕上出现的时间，大概只有一分半钟、两分钟，而人们多年后依然能记住这个角色的名字？我的意思是，能做到这一点是一种荣誉，你知道的。所以大家对这一集最想了解的事情——安吉拉，你过了一遍那些问题——就是关于意见箱。他们都想知道哪些是写好的台词，哪些是即兴发挥的。我知道我在里面有一句即兴台词被采纳了，
a lot of fun. And by the way, I saved some of those outtakes from it. And Steve Correll was so hilarious, as you remember, when he was doing the whole Chris Rock thing, it was just so funny. I was just crying, laughing, which we probably couldn't even do that episode today, you know, because it was so inappropriate in so many glorious ways, you know. Do people approach you and call you Mr. Brown? All the time. It's crazy. People say, like, I have all these different, I guess, identities to people, like some people know me from the nightly show, the day-to-day show. Some people just know me from the office and from that role, you
但他们想知道，比如有哪些没有被念出来？因为你们当时一定为那个意见箱提出了各种各样的点子。其实并没有大家想象的那么多。我觉得基本上我的初稿就直接通过并搬上荧幕了。当时我写那个的时候，还记得老约翰·卡森的节目里，他的 psychic（通灵者）是埃德·麦克马洪吗？然后约翰会做一个叫“卡纳克”的搞笑环节，他会读出一些东西，然后埃德跟着重复，你知道的。比如“骆驼的毛皮”，然后埃德会说，“骆驼的毛皮，是的。”你知道的，他会做这种桥段，这
know, and from other things that I do. But it's amazing. And they don't say Larry Wilmore, they say Mr. Brown. And that's it. That's who I am in their minds. It's not going to change. But I consider it an honor. I think how, how many times, guys, do you get to play a part where I was on screen for, what, a minute and a half, two minutes, and people remember that years later the character's name? I mean, that's an honor to do that, you know. So the biggest thing people want to know about this episode, Angela, you went through the questions. It's about the suggestion box. They all want to know what was written, what was improvised. I know I got one line
太荒谬了。我觉得如果把德怀特放在那个位置上，让他不得不跟迈克尔重复这些东西，一定会非常搞笑，我就是这样从喜剧角度构思这一段的。但它的结构，你知道的，是非常小心地引导，你知道的，引导到最终呈现的那种效果。所以我不记得意见箱里有太多东西。我的记忆是，那些东西都是经过精心挑选的，为了引导观众走向某种特定的路线，你知道的，而不是往里面塞满各种各样乱七八糟的东西。我是这么记的。这对我来说完全说得通。完全说得通。而且如果你
improvised in there that made it in, but, but they were wondering, like, what were ones that didn't get read? Like, you guys must have pitched all kinds of things for that suggestion box. Not as much as people would think. I think pretty much my first draft made it through, I think, to the floor on that one. The way that, when I wrote that, remember the old Johnny Carson show where his psychic was Ed McMahon? And, and Johnny would do this bit called Carnac, where he would read something and Ed would repeat it, you know. The fur from a camo, and then Ed would go, the fur from a camo, yes. You know, and he would do this thing, and it
从这个角度去想，当你观看时，你会发现有些镜头运动看起来非常刻意，你知道的，因为镜头在摇向那些有话要说的人。《办公室》最棒的地方在于，那些感觉像是——顺便说一句，当然，演员阵容非常才华横溢，你们的即兴表演能力也很强——但另一方面，我们在这部剧里也很幸运，那就是我们还创造了看起来非常真实的时刻，而这正是这部剧的魅力所在。我们在节目中同时拥有这两种元素。所以，那场戏，你知道的，我记得我写得非常小心，因为我知道
was so ridiculous. And I thought it would be very funny to put the white in that position where you had to repeat these things with Michael, and that's kind of how I constructed it comedically. But it was, you know, the way that it was constructed was very careful to lead, you know, to the way that it did, you know. So I don't remember there being a lot in the suggestion box. My recollection of it is that those things were chosen very carefully to go down a certain path, you know, rather than have a lot of things that were in there. That's kind of how I remember it. That makes total sense to me. It makes total sense. And also, if you
节奏很重要，喜剧节奏很重要，你知道的，所以我觉得这就是为什么那段戏没有经过太多重写，因为它本身就有一种我们想要保持完整的特定节奏。嗯，我觉得你刚才提到的一点是，人们经常没有意识到《办公室》其实是一部剧本痕迹很重的剧，人们以为它大部分是即兴发挥的，其实并不是。它大部分是按剧本演的。但你们甚至连那些眼神都会写进剧本里。在剧本里，它会写着：镜头摇向安吉拉，捕捉她在办公桌前看起来评判欲满满的表情。就像，你们开始把这些时刻也写进剧本里。
think about it like that, when you watch it, there are camera movements that look very deliberate, you know, because you're panning to the people that have something to say. The thing that was great about the office is things that feel like, by the way, of course, it was very talented cast, and your guys ability to improvise was great. But the opposite was, we were lucky to have on that too, is that we also created moments that looked very real and that sort of thing, and that was kind of the magic of the shows. We have both of those elements in the show. And so, that scene, you know, I remember very carefully writing that scene, because I
是的，正是这种元素的结合。这是我们观察你们的表现然后顺着它进行创作的结合。所以，这是一个推拉互动的过程，你知道的。尤其是，这也是为什么前五集如此重要，因为你们在做的所有事情，我们都注意到了。因为记得吗，在那些早期日子里，我觉得所有的编剧基本上全程都在片场，你知道的。我觉得我们全都在那里，看着它发生，你知道的。然后从你们的表现中学习，并试着顺着它去写台词，你知道的，以此来帮助完善它以及一切。所以……
knew the rhythm was important and at the comedic rhythm, you know, and so I think that's why there wasn't a lot of rewriting on it, because it had that certain rhythm to it that we wanted to kind of keep intact in it. Well, I think something you were mentioning that people often don't realize how written the office is, that people think it's mostly improvised, which it's not. It's mostly scripted. But you guys would even script some of those looks. You would, in the script, it would say camera pans to catch Angela looking judgy by her desk. Like, you started to write in those moments.
这确实感觉像是一次真正的创意合作。我一直都有这种感觉。而且这是一种……这真的就是。现在当我们去其他剧组工作时，你真的会注意到这一点。感觉完全不一样了，你知道的。向格雷格·丹尼尔斯致敬，你知道的，他就是想用不同的方式来做，你知道的。想要把这种合作的过程带入进来，无论是对编剧还是对演员和表演者。而且我……没有人会对此感到威胁。而且你看，想想作为主演的史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。从来没有对任何这些事情感到过威胁，你知道的，而且是如此具有合作精神，总是那么搞笑，并且乐于让其他人大放异彩。因为我们身处这个圈子，我们知道有些情况正好相反，你知道的。
Yeah, and it is that combination of things. It's the combination of us seeing what you guys were doing and then writing towards it. So, it's the push and pull of that, you know. Especially, like, that's why those first five episodes are so important, because all the stuff that, you know, you guys were doing, we noticed all of those things. Because remember, during those early days, I think all the writers were in the set the whole time, you know. I think we were all there, you know, watching it, you know. And just learning, you know, from what you guys were doing and trying to write towards it and that kind
这人是谁啊，怎么笑声全让他拿了？为什么我这里没有笑声？这部剧还有另一个非常特别的地方。正如你们所记得的那样，史蒂夫·麦钱特也是这部剧与里奇·热维斯共同的创作者。他们有时候会过来。我记得我和史蒂夫聊过这件事，关于他觉得这部剧的内核到底是什么。在史蒂夫·麦钱特看来，他总是说，对
of stuff to help develop it and everything. So... It did feel like a real creative collaboration. I always felt that way. And it's something... It really was. I miss when we go to other shows now and work on other things. Like, you really noticed it. It's not the same, you know. And kudos to Greg Daniels, you know, who just wanted to do it differently, you know. Wanted to do this collaborative process, you know, with both the writers and the actors and performers. And I don't... No one felt threatened by it. And look, think about Steve Carell as the
各种素材来协助开发等等。所以……这确实感觉像是一次真正的创意合作。我一直都是这么觉得的。而且某种程度上……确实如此。现在我去其他节目、做其他事情时我真的很怀念这一点。你会真切地注意到。感觉是不一样的，你知道的。真要感谢格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels），他就是想用不同的方式来做，你知道的。想要和编剧、演员以及表演者们进行这种合作式的创作。而且我感觉不到……没有人会因此感到威胁。你想想史蒂夫·卡瑞尔（Steve Carell）作为
star of the show. Never felt threatened by any of this stuff, you know, and just was so collaborative and just funny and just loved for other people to shine. Because we've been in this vlog and if we know how that can be the opposite, you know. Who's this person getting all these laughs, you know? Why am I not getting these laughs here? The show had something else that was really special. As you remember, Steve Merchant was also the co-creator of the show with Ricky Gervais. And they would come by sometimes. And I remember talking to Steve about it, of what he felt the show really was. And from Steve Merchant, always said that for him, the
节目的主演。从来没有对这些东西感到过任何威胁，你知道的，他总是那么注重合作，那么幽默，而且很乐于成全别人，让别人大放异彩。因为我们在这个圈子里待过，深知有时候情况会完全相反，你知道的。会想：这个人怎么出尽了风头？为什么我没有得到这些掌声？这部剧有着别的东西，非常特别。如你所记得的，史蒂夫·麦钱特（Steve Merchant）也是这部剧的联合创作人，与瑞奇·热维斯（Ricky Gervais）一起。他们有时会过来。我记得和史蒂夫聊过这件事，关于他觉得这部剧到底是什么。史蒂夫·麦钱特总是说，对闭他而言，这部
show was a romantic comedy. And it was... His idea of the show was really about Jim and Pam, you know. Jim and Don was the show to him, Jim and Pam. And to have that as part of our show, guys, it gave it this great gorgeous center that was always something great to go to. It really made like the harsh humor or the outrageous humor. It gave it a center that was special because we really wanted to root for these people. We hadn't quite seen something like that. And that was... And I never forgot that. I was like, wow, you know, sometimes in our minds we're thinking of funny jokes and outrageous things. You had diversity today. Oh, those
剧是一部浪漫喜剧。它的……他心目中的这部剧其实就是关于吉姆和潘，你知道的。对流他来说，吉姆和唐（应为吉姆和 Pam 的误读，此处可译为吉姆和潘）就是这部剧，吉姆和潘。剧里有这样一条线索，伙计们，它给整部剧提供了一个极好、极为迷人的核心，让大家总能找到一个极好的情感寄托。它真的让那种辛辣的幽默或离谱的幽默有了着落。它提供了一个特别的核心，因为我们真的很想支持这些人。我们以前没怎么见过那样的作品。那是……我永远不会忘记这一点。当时我想，哇，你知道的，有时我们在脑子里想的都是滑稽的笑话和离谱的情节。今天你遇到了多元化。哦，那些
things are funny. But when you have that romantic story inside of it, man, it just raised it to that next level. To me, it was really what made, especially in those early years, you know, when we didn't know what was going to happen with them, you know, what's going on here. This guy got his heart broken. This Pam knows what she's doing. And you know, all those questions, even when we didn't quite answer them, they were always lurking in there. And things like that really enrich your story. You know, it really makes it a joy to write that type of thing. Even to this day, I'm still trying to figure out a romantic comedy to do on television. I
东西很有趣。但当其中蕴含着那样一段浪漫的故事时，天哪，它真的把节目提升到了一个新的高度。对我而言，正是这一点，尤其是在早年间——当我们不知道他们的关系会走向何方，不知道这里到底发生了什么的时候——这个家伙心碎了，这个潘知道自己在做什么。你知道的，所有这些问题，甚至在我们还没有完全给出答案的时候，它们就一直潜藏在那里。诸如此类的事情真的极大地丰富了你的故事。你知道的，写这种类型的故事确实成了一种乐趣。直到今天，我仍然在尝试构思一部适合在电视上播出的浪漫喜剧。我
think it's kind of underserved, you know. Larry, thank you so much for coming to be on our podcast. I know you're super busy. You have a ton in development. You're producing so many things. You know, one of my goals always has been representation, trying to put stuff on television. Whether it's people we don't get a chance to see or stories we don't get a chance to see, always as much as possible. So that's always in the back of my mind. And you have a podcast. Yeah. Larry, one more black on the air. People can catch on the ringer networks too. Thank you so much for coming on. This is amazing. Thanks for having me, guys. I remain big fans of
觉得这类题材在某种程度上还不够充分，你知道的。拉里，非常感谢你来我们的播客。我知道你超级忙。你手里有很多在开发的项目。你制作了那么多的节目。你知道的，我的目标之一一直是代表性，努力把各种内容搬上电视。无论是我们平时没机会见到的人，还是我们没机会见到的故事，能展现的尽量都展现出来。所以这始终萦绕在我的脑海里。你还有一个播客。是的。拉里，又一个在播的节目。人们也可以在 Ringer 网络上收听。非常感谢你能来。这太棒了。谢谢你们邀请我，伙计们。我一直是你们
both of you. Congrats on all your great success. So you guys have to come on my podcast now that I did yours. Okay, deal. It's a date. Okay, you got it. It sounds great. All right, Larry, thank you so much. Thank you, Larry. We love you. Aw, that was so great. He's so smart and funny. Why do I get so emotional every time we just hear the voices of the people we worked with? I don't know. Because we were a family. We were a family. All right, well, we're gonna take a break. So I can be emotional. I'll pull myself together and we'll be back to break down the episode. Larry is fantastic. That was great. That was so fun to talk to him. We're so lucky.
两人的超级粉丝。祝贺你们取得的所有巨大成功。既然我上了你们的播客，你们也得来我的播客。好的，成交。一言为定。行，就这么说定了。听起来太棒了。好的，拉里，非常感谢你。谢谢你，拉里。我们爱你。啊，太棒了。他太聪明、太幽默了。为什么每次听到我们合作过的人的声音，我都会变得这么情绪化？我不知道。因为我们是一个家庭。我们是一个家庭。好吧，我们要休息一下。好让我能平复情绪。我要调整一下自己，然后回来继续剖析这一集。拉里太棒了。太棒了。和他聊天太有趣了。我们太幸运了。
We're so lucky. All right, should we get into the episode? Let's get into performance review. I know we covered a little bit of the stunt aspect of the fitness orb, but we have not discussed the other elements of the cold open, the romance. You mean the look to camera that Dwight gave at 50 seconds? Yes. When Jim is like, you're not having sex. He's like, mm-hmm. What does that look about? I think we're gonna find out. I think we might. All right, so in the first scene, Oscar is walking out of Michael's office. He's just completed his performance review, and Michael calls Pam into his office. I think you can tell in my talking head there that I'm very
我们太幸运了。好吧，我们要开始聊这一集了吗？让我们进入绩效评估环节。我知道我们之前稍微讨论了一下健身球的特技部分，但我们还没有讨论冷开场的其他元素，也就是浪漫部分。你是说德怀特在第50秒时对镜头的那个眼神吗？是的。当时吉姆说，你没有在做爱。然后他挑了挑眉，嗯哼。那个眼神是什么意思？我想我们会找到答案的。我想我们可能会。好的，所以在第一个场景中，奥斯卡从迈克尔的办公室走出来。他刚完成绩效评估，然后迈克尔把潘叫进了办公室。我想从我的访谈画面里可以看出我当时非常
sick. I don't know. I think I sound very nasally. I mean, if you can't tell, you're literally like, here's the furthest review. I know. So in that office, when Michael makes Pam listen to the voicemail from Jan, that was my sickest day. That was the day I was most sick. And I think you can see me a little bit nodding off, like not nodding off. No. I think you can see me drifting from the Sudafed. Like I'm a little like. Your eyes are a little glassy. They are. A little dilated. They're a little glassy, but it has one of my favorite scenes. Jenna, it made me laugh so hard. You and Steve were so great. And I just loved when he's like, Pam, you're
生病。我不知道。我觉得我的声音听起来有很多鼻音。我是说，如果你听不出来，你就直接说，这是最远的评估。我懂。所以在那个办公室里，当迈克尔让潘听简留下的语音留言时，那是我病得最重的一天。那是我病得最厉害的一天。我想你可以看到我有点在打瞌睡，也不是打瞌睡。没有。我想你可以看到我因为吃伪麻黄碱（Sudafed）而有点走神。就像我有点……你的眼神有点呆滞。确实。有点放大。眼神有点呆滞，但这是我最喜欢的场景之一。珍娜，它把我逗得太开心了。你和史蒂夫演得太棒了。我特别喜欢当他说，潘，你是
trustworthy. Wait, can we re... I was acting out. Yeah. Do it. All right. I'll be Michael. You be yourself, right? All right. Pam, you're trustworthy. Thank you. And a woman. Oh, no. It made me laugh so hard. I know. She just knows where that's going. And it's not good news. So we had a fan question about this from Luke Jay. Was the scene with you talking to Michael about Jan's voicemails improvised? No, it wasn't. But here's an interesting fact. We weren't listening to a recording. That was actually Melora, who plays Jan on the phone, saying that voicemail in the exact same way over and over again. Yeah. And he would hit that button. He would hit
值得信赖。等等，我们可以重……我在耍宝。好。开始吧。好吧。我来演迈克尔。你演你自己，对吧？好吧。帕姆，你很值得信赖。谢谢。还有女人。哦，不。这把我逗得前仰后合。我知道。她就是知道事情会变成那样。而且这可不是什么好消息。所以我们有一个关于这个的粉丝提问，来自卢克·杰伊。你和迈克尔谈论简的语音留言的那场戏是即兴发挥的吗？不，不是的。但这里有个有趣的事实。我们当时听的不是录音。在电话那头说那些语音留言的其实是梅洛拉，也就是在剧中扮演简的演员，她一遍又一遍用完全相同的方式说。是的。而且他会按那个按钮。他会按
that button and she would be cued to say it. I think she was right in the conference room. Yeah. I think she was right around the corner. She was. She was on set talking through the phone. And I feel like our second AD would cue her. And whenever Michael hit the button, she might could have even have seen him actually, depending where she was standing. That was so funny. So good. And there's deleted scenes. And if you look at it, there's one deleted scene where Steve keeps pressing the button like 12 times and she just had to keep saying, I guess I missed you. I guess I missed you. I guess I missed you. I guess I missed
那个按钮，然后她就会得到提示开始说。我想她当时就在会议室里。是的。我想她就在拐角处。她确实在那。她就在片场通过电话说话。我觉得我们的第二副导演会给她提示。而且每当迈克尔按下按钮时，她甚至可能都能看到他，这取决于她当时站在哪里。太好笑了。太棒了。还有删减片段。如果你仔细看，有一个删减片段是史蒂夫不停地按按钮，大概按了12次，而她就只能不停地说，我猜我错过你了。我猜我错过你了。我猜我错过你了。我猜我错过
you. I guess I missed you until she starts laughing. Yeah, because he was like insane. Okay. At two minutes and 51 seconds, there was a flashback to the exterior of the chilies and you get a wide shot of that chilies from the previous episode that we talked about and you see them kissing outside. I really scrutinized the shot of the chilies. I want to hear it. Remember in the last episode we said, was this the same chilies that we shot the dundies? Oh yeah, you were obsessed with that. Now I think it was not really based on the exterior of the parking lot. Yes. This shot is different than any shot we got
你了。我猜我错过你了，直到她笑场。对，因为他简直就像疯了一样。好吧。在2分51秒的时候，有一个闪回镜头，是辣椒餐厅的外景，你会看到我们之前讨论过的上一集里辣椒餐厅的广角镜头，然后你看到他们在外面接吻。我仔细审视了辣椒餐厅的镜头。我想听听。还记得上一集我们说过吗，这和我们拍摄邓迪奖时的是同一个辣椒餐厅吗？哦，对，你对这个很执着。现在我觉得从停车场的外观来看其实并不是。是的。这个镜头和我们在
in the client. This is a wide shot. And I think it looks like a different parking lot and a different exterior than the one that Pam comes out of the dundies screaming, woohoo. All right, I'm going to have to go back and look at that. Okay, way to go, lady. Also, maybe no one cares, but we all care. I have a card from five minutes. Is that jumping too far ahead for you? Who knows? Okay, who knows? I don't write time codes. I have a card for five minutes, five seconds. It's just me commenting you guys as a fan. I just thought John's reaction when he is Jim realizes that Dwight thinks it's the wrong date. His
《客户》里拍的任何镜头都不一样。这是一个广角镜头。而且我觉得它看起来和一个不同的停车场以及不同的外景地不同，而不是帕姆从辣椒餐厅尖叫着走出来喊“呜呼”的那一个。好吧，我得回去看看那个。好吧，干得好，女士。还有，可能没人关心，但我们都在乎。我有一张记录着5分钟的卡片。这对于你来说是不是跳得太远了？谁知道呢。好吧，谁知道呢？我不写时间码。我有一张记录着5分钟5秒的卡片。这只是我作为粉丝对你们的评价。我只是觉得当吉姆意识到
performance in that little moment is so brilliant because it's really letting you in on that he's figuring something out. Yeah. And it's subtle and it's perfect. And John, you crushed it. Yeah. Those are the those are the ways that John just like, he's amazing. He's so good. John, you're so good. I'm like, I'm just like, I've always been a fan and I think I'm just like becoming a bigger fan as I rewatch. Here's something about that same scene. I don't know if you notice, but in the background over John's shoulder, Michael's door is closed. Here's a little tidbit. When you see scenes between Jim and Dwight and Michael's
德怀特以为那是错误的日期时，约翰的反应。他在那个小片段里的表现太精彩了，因为它真的让你了解到他正在琢磨出一些事情。是的。而且它很微妙，也很完美。约翰，你演得太棒了。是的。这就是约翰的那种方式，他太棒了。他太厉害了。约翰，你太棒了。我当时就想，我一直都是个粉丝，我觉得在我重温的过程中，我好像变成了更大的粉丝。关于同一场戏还有这样一件事。我不知道你们有没有注意到，但是在约翰肩膀背景中的迈克尔的办公室门是关着的。这里有个小花絮。当你看到吉姆和德怀特之间发生冲突，而迈克尔的
door is closed, that meant that Steve didn't have to sit in there. Oh, good for Steve. Yeah, he would get a break from having to do the background work because when the door was open, you could see him at his desk, but when the door is closed, you can't guess what none of the rest of us had doors. Nope. None of the rest of us had doors unless you're in the annex. So Steve, Steve got out of the background for that couple of hours that we shot that scene. I have a card for seven minutes, 50 seconds. You guys, it's a scene and accounting. So here's the thing when Brian and Oscar and I got to have a scene that was solely in
门是关着的时候，这意味着史蒂夫不需要坐在里面。哦，史蒂夫太走运了。是的，他可以不用做背景表演，因为当门开着的时候，你能看到他在他的办公桌前，但当门关着的时候，你看不见。你猜怎么着，我们其余所有人都没有门。没有。我们其余所有人都没有门，除非你在 annex。所以史蒂夫，史蒂夫在我们拍摄那场戏的那几个小时里不用当背景板。我有一张记录着7分50秒的卡片。各位，这是会计部的一场戏。所以情况是这样的，当布莱恩、奥斯卡和我拍一场纯粹发生在
accounting, we would get just giddy. We would get so excited and like we would come up with all of these bits and they would always be like, guys, we don't have time for all of that. We used to joke, you know, like I would say, like, guys, it's not our show. It's not called the accountants. So we were really excited, but when I was watching this, I thought, Oh my God, Kevin is such a gossip. Oh, yes. He's so gossipy when he's like, they made out, you know, hand hood sex, like he's being so gross. And then of course, what the heck does my comment mean? When I say office romances are nobody's business, but the
会计部的戏时，我们会兴奋得头晕目眩。我们会变得超级兴奋，我们会想出所有的段子，然后他们总是会说，伙计们，我们没有时间搞那么多。我们过去常常开玩笑，你知道的，比如我会说，伙计们，这不是我们的节目。这不叫《会计师》。所以我们真的很兴奋，但当我看到这个时，我想，哦，天哪，凯文真是个八卦狂。哦，是的。他太八卦了，当他说，他们亲热了，你知道的，手摸那啥的性行为，就像他表现得太恶心了。然后当然，我的评论到底是什么意思？当我说办公室恋情不关任何人的事，除了
people involved. What's happening between Dwight's look and that line? I know. We're weaving something together here. Something's happening. I want to talk about Stanley's meeting with Michael. Oh gosh, you know what? Leslie, David Baker is so brilliant in the scene. I actually wanted to call Leslie. Dang it. Okay, Leslie, we're gonna call you. You've got to come in, but I wrote on a card. Just tell, just read what I wrote on the ghetto, on the ghetto. Well, that was a fan question. Drew's fire asked about Stanley saying on the ghetto instead of in the ghetto. Was this intentional? It was, it was not improvised. It was written. Paul
当事人。德怀特的表情和那句台词之间发生了什么？我知道。我们在这里把一些东西编织在一起。有些事情正在发生。我想谈谈斯坦利与迈克尔的会面。哦天哪，你知道吗，莱斯利·大卫·贝克在那场戏里太出色了。我其实想给莱斯利打电话。可恶。好吧，莱斯利，我们要给你打电话。你得来参与，但我写在卡片上了。只要说，只要读我写在 ghetto 上的，ghetto 上的。好吧，那是粉丝提问。德鲁的火气问到关于斯坦利说的是“on the ghetto”而不是“in the ghetto”。这是故意的吗？是的，这不是即兴发挥的。是写好的。保罗
Lieberstein wrote the line on the ghetto and there was a debate in the writer's room about which was funnier for Stanley to say in the ghetto or on the ghetto, on the ghetto one. Leslie, David Baker delivered it perfectly. I just love how he is working Michael so hard in the scene. I loved watching Pam work Michael and then Stanley and be like, oh my gosh, they're all doing it. They're all giving him relationship advice to get a good performance review. Yes. Well, that's what you have to do. I also love the scene in the kitchen with Jim and Pam where it's a really quick scene where Pam's just walking to the bathroom and they just
·利伯斯坦写了“on the ghetto”这句台词，编剧室里曾有一场争论，关于斯坦利说“in the ghetto”还是“on the ghetto”哪个更好笑，结果“on the ghetto”赢了。莱斯利·大卫·贝克的演绎堪称完美。我只是很喜欢他在那场戏里把迈克尔拿捏得死死的。我喜欢看帕姆拿捏迈克尔，然后是斯坦利，就像，哦天哪，他们都在这么做。他们都在给他提供恋爱建议，以求获得好的绩效考核。是的。嗯，这就是你必须要做的。我也很喜欢厨房里吉姆和帕姆的那场戏，那是一场非常快的戏，帕姆只是走去洗浴室，他们只是
quickly download each other on the day. Oh, by the way, Dwight thinks it's Friday instead of Thursday and then Pam says her little tidbit to Jim and they move on. That totally reminded me of me and my husband. Yeah. Sometimes that's all you get. You just between packing lunches and doing laundry and pick up and drop off and all the things that keep the house running. You got to just, you'll get like two sentences out before someone needs something from you. And sometimes it's like a big reveal because like you walked by and you're like, they definitely hooked up. He's like, oh yeah, Dwight thinks it's Thursday or
迅速向对方同步这一天的进展。哦，对了，德怀特以为今天是星期五而不是星期四，然后帕姆对吉姆说了她的小八卦，然后他们就继续了。这完全让我想到了我和我丈夫。是的。有时候你得到的就只有这些。你只是在打包午餐、洗衣服、接送孩子以及所有让这个家运转的事情之间。你必须只能这样，你只能在别人需要你之前说上两句话。有时这就像一个重大爆料，因为你走过去说，他们绝对有一腿。他说，哦，是的，德怀特以为今天是星期四或
Friday. Oh, great. Yes, big news. Big news, but you don't have a ton of time. Exactly. And I feel like Lee and I download one another sometimes, you know, with stuff like that, big stuff. Scenes like that make our show so special, I think, because they don't feel like a scene. You really feel like you're just watching someone live their life and I think it's super unique to our show. Like you're just capturing a moment in time. And I also think it's such a great way to write the romance between Jim and Pam. Like I think that's intimacy, right? Like that's why it made me think of me and my husband because they have
星期五。哦，太棒了。是的，大新闻。大新闻，但你没有多少时间。没错。我觉得我和李有时也会互相同步，你知道的，关于那种事情，大事。这样的戏让我们的节目变得非常特别，我认为，因为它们感觉不像是一场戏。你真的觉得你只是在看着别人过他们的人生，我觉得这对于我们的节目来说超级独特。就像你只是捕捉到了一个时间片段。而且我也觉得这是编写吉姆和帕姆之间浪漫史的一种绝佳方式。就像我认为这就是亲密感，对吧？就像这就是为什么它让我想起我和我丈夫，因为他们必须抓住这种亲密时刻。
to grab this moment of intimacy. Wherever they can. Yeah. And so it really makes them feel like a couple because you can do that with someone you're really close with. Yep. You can download big info in two seconds. Yolkhan. I don't know why I said it like that. Yolkhan, I have a card. What is it? Nine minutes, two seconds. Kelly's hair is up. What? Kelly Kapoor. Hold on. Her hair is in a bun or up due this whole episode. Oh, yes. What is happening? I don't know. Oh, yes. I have that too. Michael tells everybody about the suggestion box meeting and Kelly's hair is back up in a twist with a paisley shirt. But I did think that Mindy
无论他们能在哪里。是的。所以这真的让他们感觉像是一对情侣，因为你可以和非常亲近的人做到这一点。没错。你可以在两秒钟内同步重大信息。Yolkhan。我不知道我为什么要那样说。Yolkhan，我有一张卡片。是什么？9分钟2秒。凯莉把头发扎起来了。什么？凯莉·卡普尔。等等。她的头发在这整集里都盘着或者扎着。哦，是的。发生什么了？我不知道。哦，是的。我也有这个。迈克尔向所有人讲述了意见箱会议，凯莉的头发又盘成了一个发髻，穿着一件佩斯利花纹衬衫。但我确实觉得曼迪
was acting more Mindy-ish. Yes. So her performance is evolved even though her hair is fussy. Her hair is fussy, but she's becoming more like Mindy. Angela, I have to go back though. Oh, what? We have to discuss your youth beauty pageant. Oh, yes. Okay. And your love of being judged. Jake Peters asked, what was Angela's talent when she was on the pageant circuit? Angela, what do you think her talent would be? I mean, there was a prop photo of me twirling a baton. I don't know if it ever made it in an episode. Oh, I remember that. Yeah. So I don't know if I was a baton twirler. You know what? If I got to pick what
的表现更像曼迪了。是的。所以她的表演进化了，尽管她的头发很繁复。她的头发很繁复，但她变得越来越像曼迪了。安吉拉，我得回去了。哦，什么？我们得讨论一下你的少年选美比赛。哦，是的。好吧，还有你对被评判的热爱。杰克·彼得斯问，安吉拉参加选美比赛时的才艺是什么？安吉拉，你觉得她的才艺会是什么？我是说，我有一张拿着指挥棒转动的道具照片。我不知道它有没有出现在某一集里。哦，我记得那个。是的。所以，我不知道我是不是一个转指挥棒的人。你知道吗？如果让我选择
Angela's beauty pageant talent would be, it would be that she would play the crystal glasses. That is so perfect. She would have a table of glasses and be like, and she'd play like maybe like some old gospel tune. I feel like either that or the bells. Oh, the bells with the gloves on. Yes. Yes. Those two things. Okay. I have something. At nine minutes, 16 seconds, there's another scene between Jim and Dwight at their desks. This is when Jim is on the phone and you can see that Michael's door is open and Steve is in the background. Okay. He did not get out of that one. I like it. I like how like I would track like who was sitting
安吉拉的选美才艺会是什么，那就是她会弹奏水晶玻璃。这太完美了。她会有一张摆满玻璃杯的桌子，然后就像，她会弹奏一些旧的福音曲调。我觉得要么是这个，要么是铃铛。哦，戴着手套敲铃铛。是的。是的，就这两样东西。好吧。我有一个。在9分16秒时，吉姆和德怀特在他们的办公桌之间还有一场戏。这是吉姆在打电话的时候，你可以看到迈克尔的门是开着的，史蒂夫在背景里。好吧。他这次没躲过去。我喜欢。我喜欢我怎么追踪谁坐在
with Oscar in his booth at the Dundee's. Yeah. This is your, this is like Steve's door is open. Steve's door is closed. This is going to be my thing. Yeah. I'm just going to be like, you're in charge of the door lady. I'm okay. Great. Okay. I'll be door. I'm on door. Horror door. Oh, you don't watch Game of Thrones. I don't. What is it? What door? Horror door. Horror door? Horror? No. Like a, is it a hood door? Oh, sorry. I said it wrong. Hodor? It's hodor. Hodor. Hodor. It's sort of the same. What happens in the, I mean, all that's coming to mind for me is prostitution. No. What is this door? Don't listen to my southern accent. Hodor. It's
邓迪奖的卡座里和奥斯卡在一起。是的。这是你的，这就像史蒂夫的门是开着的。史蒂夫的门是关着的。这将成为我的事情。是的。我只会说，女士，你负责门。我很好。太好了。好的。我来负责门。我负责门。Hodor 门。哦，你没看过《权力的游戏》。我没有。那是什么？什么门？Hodor 门。Hodor 门？Hodor？不。就像，是一个 ho 门吗？哦，对不起，我念错了。Hodor？是 Hodor。Hodor。Hodor。这有点像。在里发生了什么，我是说，我脑子里浮现的只有卖淫。不。这扇门是什么？别听我的南方口音。Hodor。是
hodor. Even still ho, hodor. Jenna, it's not about. What happens with the door? Just tell me. Well, it's not about prostitutes. Okay. Well, what is it? It's a person. Hodor is a person. Oh, it's not a door? No, but a door is involved later. I don't want to ruin it for you. It's my hope that someday you'll watch Game of Thrones. I'm never going to watch it, Angela. I'm sorry to tell you. Come on. Hodor. It's not my genre. What? Fantasy is not my genre. So you don't like Lord of the Rings? I've never seen it. I'm out. I'm out. She's leaving. She took off her headphones. No, you know this about me. I mean, I sort of knew it, but come on. Lord of the Rings.
Hodor。即使这样 ho，Hodor。珍娜，这不是关于。门发生了什么？直接告诉我。嗯，这跟妓女无关。好吧，那是什么？是一个人。Hodor 是一个人。哦，不是一扇门？不，但后来涉及了一扇门。我不想给你剧透。我希望有一天你能看《权力的游戏》。我永远不会看的，安吉拉。我很遗憾地告诉你。拜托。Hodor。这不是我的类型。什么？奇幻不是我的类型。所以你不喜欢《指环王》？我从来没看过。我不看了。我不看了。她走了。她摘下了耳机。不，你了解我的。我的意思是，我多少知道一点，但是拜托。《指环王》。
It's just, you know what it is. I'm not a fan of having to learn all new rules about different new planets or weight, mythical creatures and their powers. Hold up. What? I don't, I can't even, I almost can't say this out loud. What? What? Do you not like Star Wars? No. No. I'm afraid to speak right now. No, Jenna, are you kidding? You don't like Star Wars? I have not ever. What? Seen. No. The Star Wars movies. No. Except I think as a child, I saw the Empire Strikes Back. Oh my God. I have an appreciation for Star Wars as a cultural phenomenon. Oh my God, you sound, you sound like, this sounds like you're a politician. Oh my God. When I was a child, I went to Star Wars and I fell asleep
这只是，你知道是怎么回事。我不喜欢去学习关于不同新星球的所有新规则，或者等待，神话生物及其超能力。等等。什么？我甚至，我几乎不能大声说出来这个。什么？什么？你不喜欢《星际大战》吗？不。不。我此刻害怕说话。不，珍娜，你在开玩笑吗？你不喜欢《星际大战》？我从来没有。什么？看过。不。《星际大战》电影。没有。除了我想我小时候看过《帝国反击战》。哦，天哪。我对《星际大战》作为一种文化现象有着欣赏。哦，天哪，你听起来，你听起来像，这听起来像个政客。哦，天哪。当我还是个孩子的时候，我去看了《星际大战》，然后我在
during it. And then as an adult, I thought, what is wrong with me? I need to see Star Wars. And then you were like, but then I have to learn rules about a new planet. No, I fell asleep again. Oh my God. And then I thought that's a sign. I mean, in multiple generations of myself or like in different decades. Here's the thing though, I was obsessed with Princess Leia. Like as a kid, I wore the buns and I did the lightsaber fighting. But you didn't know why. No, I don't know any of the things. I don't know where Chewbacca is from. But then likewise, I love your baby Yoda. You have a knitted baby Yoda. I do. In your she shed office. And I love it. I want one. But so I guess I'm attracted to parts of Star Wars,
电影中睡着了。然后作为一个成年人，我想，我怎么了？我需要看《星际大战》。然后你当时就想，但随后我必须学习关于一个新星球的规则。不，我又睡着了。哦，天哪。然后我想这是一个信号。我是说，在我生命的多个世代或者不同的十年里。不过事情是这样的，我曾经迷恋莱娅公主。就像小时候一样，我梳着发髻，还玩光剑对决。但你不知道为什么。不，我什么都不知道。我不知道丘巴卡来自哪里。但同样地，我喜欢你的尤达宝宝。你有一个针织的尤达宝宝。我有。在你的女性专属小屋办公室里。我超爱它。我也想要一个。所以我想我被《星际大战》的部分内容所吸引，
but not the actual story or any of the rules. Wow. I'm afraid that I've said this. I'm afraid. Don't be afraid. I'm afraid to have admitted this. This feels like a little bit like I'm telling a secret. It is. No, it's you know, listen, we went to Disneyland and we rode that Millennium Falcon ride. I loved the whole Disneyland Star Wars world. Like I didn't want to leave. It was amazing. It was so well done. And then like the ride was blew my mind. Like I've seen so much of the imagery from the movie that I was giddy. I think Jenna, that in 2020, I think you need to read the Star Wars. I think you have to. Okay, Angela, the Mandalorian. It's so good. What is that? It's on Disney Plus. Oh God,
但不是实际的故事或任何规则。哇。我害怕我说出了这些。我害怕。别害怕。我害怕承认这一点。这感觉有点像我在保守秘密。确实。不，你知道的，听着，我们去了迪士尼乐园，我们坐了那个千年隼号的飞游。我喜欢整个迪士尼乐园的《星际大战》世界。就像我不想离开一样。太棒了。做得太好了。然后那个游乐设施让我大开眼界。就像我从电影中看到了那么多的视觉形象，以至于我欣喜若狂。珍娜，我觉得在2020年，我觉得你应该读读《星际大战》。我觉得你必须读。好吧，安吉拉，《曼达洛人》。太棒了。那是什么？在 Disney Plus 上。哦天哪，
it's got baby Yoda in it. I please don't make me watch all these fantasy shows. What if I bought like this would be like if I said to you, Angela, in 2020, I'm going to make you watch all my favorite horror movies. Oh, I do hate horror movies. See, I hate them. I love horror movies. And I love in particular survivalist horror movies. Oh, I hate those. Okay, fine. Okay, fine. You can keep your survivalist movies and I'll keep Star Wars. Although I do feel like there might be a night. Listen to me. Listen to me. Well, you come to my house with me this year and watch my annual viewing of the edge. And in exchange, I'll watch something of your fantasy stuff. Yes. But if I have to watch a man fight a
里面有尤达宝宝。我求求你别让我看所有这些奇幻剧了。如果我买了这个就像我对你说，安吉拉，在2020年，我要让你看我所有最喜欢的恐怖电影。哦，我确实讨厌恐怖电影。你看，我讨厌它们。我喜欢恐怖电影。我尤其喜欢求生类恐怖电影。哦，我讨厌那些。好吧，好吧。你可以保留你的求生电影，我保留《星际大战》。虽然我觉得可能会有一个晚上。听我说。听我说。今年你跟我一起来我家，看我每年例行的观看《边缘》。作为交换，我会看一些你的奇幻玩意儿。好。但如果我必须看一个男人与一
bear, like the bear is eating him and he's fighting him off, I'm going to need a glass of wine. You can have a glass of wine. It's going to stress me the hell out. Well, Angela, what one man has done another can do. Oh my God, there it is. Okay, fine. I have spoken. Yes! Yes, Mandalorian! Yes! I don't know what that reference is. I know, I know. Let's get back to the episode. If anyone is still willing to listen to me after that confession, the scene with Jan and Michael greeting one another where he accidentally touches her boob. Yes. I know. Do you remember on the day we rehearsed that scene because it was a little tricky. There was a big camera movement of Michael watching the door waiting for Jan
只熊搏斗，就像那只熊在吃他而他在反抗，我需要一杯葡萄酒。你可以喝一杯葡萄酒。这会把我压力山大死。好吧，安吉拉，一个人能做到另一个人也能做到。哦天哪，就是这样。好吧。我心意已决。太棒了！太棒了！《曼达洛人》！太棒了！我不知道那个梗是什么。我知道，我知道。我们回到这一集吧。如果在那次坦白之后还有人愿意听我说话的话，简和迈克尔互相打招呼的那场戏，他意外地摸了她的胸部。是的。我知道。你还记得那天我们排练那场戏吗，因为这有点棘手。有一个巨大的摄像机运动，迈克尔看着门等待简
and then he comes out of his office. So it was a little complicated. We had to really rehearse that with the cameras. And during the rehearsal, Steve accidentally touched her boob. Yes. And we all left so hard. Malora was cracking up. Malora said, you have to do that in a take. And Steve was like, no, no, no. And she's like, no, it was so funny and awkward. You have to. And so then that became a bit in the scene. Then they had to try to do it where it still looked like an accident, which is a really hard thing to do actually. Yeah, because he was just... To recreate that. I think Steve was just trying to pat her shoulder and missed. Yes. She sort of moved a little bit and he accidentally
然后他从他的办公室出来。所以这有点复杂。我们必须真正带着摄像机排练那场戏。在排练期间，史蒂夫不小心摸了她的胸部。是的。我们都笑得前仰后合。梅洛拉笑崩了。梅洛拉说，你必须在实拍中这样做。史蒂夫则说，不，不，不。她说，不，太好笑也太尴尬了。你必须这么做。所以后来这就成了戏里的一个梗。然后他们必须试着把它演得看起来仍然像个意外，这实际上是一件非常难做到的事。是的，因为他只是……要重现那一幕。我觉得史蒂夫当时只是想拍拍她的肩膀却没打中。是的。她稍微转了一下身，他就不小心
patted her boob. Yeah, she turned into him as he went to pat her shoulder. So funny. So funny. That was a complete accident that bit. That just happened on the fly. I also want to say that then when Jan goes into Michael's office, I love that the cameras are outside of the office during the scene between Michael and Jan. So Paul Feig talked about his decision to keep the cameras outside the office for these scenes. He thought that Michael might want Jan alone so that he could ask her about the relationship. And so the... And Jan would not want the cameras there anyway. No, probably not. And so they had to get it as a spy shot. But then later, after the suggestion box meeting, you'll notice that the camera is inside the
拍到了她的胸部。是的，当他去拍她的肩膀时，她转身朝向了他。太好笑了。太好笑了。那完全是个意外，那个梗。那是即兴发生的。我还想说，当简走进迈克尔的办公室时，我喜欢在迈克尔和简的那场戏中摄像机是在办公室外面的。所以保罗·费格谈到了他决定在这些场景中让摄像机留在办公室外面的决定。他认为迈克尔可能想单独和简在一起，这样他就可以问她关于恋情的事。所以……而且简无论如何也不想摄像机在那里。不，可能不想。所以他们不得不把它拍成偷拍镜头。但后来，在意见箱会议之后，你会注意到摄像机在
room with them. And Paul said that his logic was that in Michael's mind, if he let the cameras in the office with him, maybe Jan couldn't yell at him as much for what happened in the conference room. Oh, yes. So Michael would be able to use the camera as a buffer. As protection. I just love the thoughtfulness that goes into the planning of where the camera is or where the camera isn't. I mean, that's just... Paul is so smart. He's so smart. Well, I loved the line that Jan had when she said, please don't smell me, Michael. Oh, yes. He's like, what are you wearing? Smell sexy? She's like, oh God, don't smell me. That reminds me so much of Pam's line. Please don't throw garbage at me. Me too. It reminded me of the
房间里和他们在一起。保罗说他的逻辑是，在迈克尔的脑海里，如果他让摄像机和他在办公室里，也许简就不会因为会议室里发生的事情而对他大喊大叫了。哦，是的。所以迈克尔能够把摄像机当作缓冲。当作保护。我只是喜欢在规划摄像机在哪里或不在哪里时所投入的那种周到。我的意思是，那只是……保罗太聪明了。他太聪明了。嗯，我很喜欢简的那句台词，当她说，请不要闻我，迈克尔。哦，是的。他就像，你穿的什么？闻起来很性感？她说，哦天哪，别闻我。这太让我想起帕姆的那句台词了。请不要向我扔垃圾。我也是。这让我想起了
same thing. Hey guys, just a little fun background thing to catch. There is a British flag on Michael's desk. You see it throughout the episode whenever you go into his office. I like to think it's a little nod to our BBC roots. It must be, right? I think so. Yeah. They would do stuff like that. I know. So I don't know if you guys noticed it, but I noticed it right away. In the conference room, 12 minutes, 26 seconds, we are opening up the suggestion box. We had a fan question from Real Brand in B16. What was the hardest scene for you to film for this episode? This one. We laughed so much. So hard. I laughed so hard at every one of Steve's reactions. Everything was so, and also like rain is
同样的事情。嘿伙计们，只是一个捕捉背景的小趣事。迈克尔的桌子上有一面英国国旗。每当你走进他的办公室时，你在整集里都能看到它。我愿意认为这是对我们BBC之根的一个小致敬。一定是的，对吧？我想是的。是的。他们会做那样的事。我知道。所以我不知道你们有没有注意到，但我马上就注意到了。在会议室里，12分26秒，我们正在打开意见箱。我们有一个来自 B16 的 Real Brand 的粉丝提问。对你来说，拍摄这一集最难的一场戏是哪一场？这一场。我们笑得太多了。笑得太厉害了。我对史蒂夫的每一个反应都笑得前仰后合。一切都那么，而且还有像雷恩是
white, like, like repeating all the ridiculous things. So good. Also, I think in this scene, there's some Toby sass. Oh, I wrote major Toby sass. Okay. So wait, first of all, can we just briefly talk about how many cards are in the suggestion box? Yes, please. There are six. Okay. Number one, what should we do to prepare for Y2K? Amazing. Number two, we need better outreach for employees fighting depression. Okay. That was Tom. Number three, you need to do something about your B.O. This is when we have major Toby sass. Yes. Because he's like, Michael, aren't these about you? And he's like, I mean, I can't believe, so I can't, first of all, I can't believe Michael didn't kick him out of the conference room.
怀特，就像，就像重复所有荒谬的事情。太棒了。还有，我觉得在这个场景中，有一些托比的傲慢。哦，我记下了重大的托比傲慢。好的。所以等等，首先，我们能简单谈谈意见箱里有多少张卡片吗？好的，请。有六张。好的。第一，我们应该做些什么来为千年虫做准备？太惊人了。第二，我们需要为与抑郁症斗争的员工提供更好的帮助。好的。那是汤姆。第三，你得对你的体味做点什么。这是我们遭遇重大托比傲慢的时候。是的。因为他就像，迈克尔，这些不是关于你的吗？他就像，我的意思是，我简直不敢相信，所以我不能，首先，我简直不敢相信迈克尔没有把他踢出会议室。
Yeah. Yeah. Right. And I think he only didn't kick him out because Jan was there. Yes. Good call. Also, can we all just take a minute to witness the fact that Creed, like, schooled Michael and the difference between inferring and implying? Yes. Like what Creed? I love when Creed suddenly lays down real wisdom. Yeah. And we're like, what? Yeah. Mostly says gibberish. And then you're like, Oh, okay. Take note. Inferring and implying are two different things. What? Number four, you need to do something about your coffee breath, which was clearly my character's card. Yes. Yes. Number five, a piece of gum. Number six, don't sleep with your boss. Yes. Yeah. I personally never came back from the gum.
是的。是的。对吧。而且我觉得他之所以没把他踢出去，只是因为简在场。是的。好判断。还有，大家能花点时间见证一下克里夫，就像，在推断和暗示的区别上教育了迈克尔吗？是的。就像克里夫什么鬼。我喜欢克里夫突然吐露真正智慧的时候。是的。而我们就像，什么？大部分时间都在说胡话。然后你会觉得，哦，好吧。记住。推断和暗示是两回事。什么？第四，你得对你的咖啡口气做点什么，这显然是我角色的卡片。是的。是的。第五，一块口香糖。第六，不要和你的老板睡觉。是的。是的。我个人从来没有从口香糖那一幕里缓过来。
When he opens up the piece of gum and Steve's reaction to the gum. Yeah. I don't think I ever got it together after that because it was so amazing. Also, watch Mindy at 15 minutes, 10 seconds. She puts her hand over her mouth, but her eyes get really wide. Like she's totally, it's a total giveaway. She's laughing. That's what Mindy does when she laughs. She covers her mouth with her hand. Yes. That's her tell. All right. So now we're going to move out to the stairwell and the scene where Dwight is pumping himself up for his performance review to the song Wild Side by Motley Crue. Yes. So that is the stairwell to the writer's offices. The bottom of the stairs is the hallway where our editors would sit. That's where
当他打开那块口香糖，以及史蒂夫对口香糖的反应时。是的。我觉得我之后再也没有整理好情绪，因为它太神奇了。还有，在15分10秒的时候看曼迪。她把手放在嘴上，但她的眼睛睁得非常大。就像她完全，这是一个彻底的暴露。她在笑。那就是曼迪笑时的表现。她用手捂住嘴。是的。那是她的破绽。好吧。所以现在我们要走到楼梯间，那是德怀特伴随着莫特莉·克鲁乐队的歌曲《Wild Side》为自己的绩效考核打气的场景。是的。所以那是通往编剧办公室的楼梯间。楼梯底部是我们编辑坐的走廊。那是
the editing bays were. And upstairs was the writers. And Rain has said in interviews that this was one of his favorite scenes to film. And I happened to be over in the writer's room that day that they were filming it and I sat at the top of the stairs and I watched him film the scene. Yes. And it was so great. And a lot of the stuff that he is saying there was improvised. Yes. As his, also people were like, did he improvise playing the air guitar? That's all Rain. That's all Rain. And there was something funny about that. So usually when you have music in a scene, they don't actually play the music on set. In fact, they'll be like a big dance scene or a club scene, like let's say you're shooting a wedding.
剪辑室所在的地方。楼上是编剧。雷恩在采访中说过，这是他最喜欢拍摄的场景之一。碰巧那天他们拍摄时我在编剧室那边，我坐在楼梯顶上看着他拍这场戏。是的。而且太棒了。他在那里说的很多东西都是即兴发挥的。是的。作为他的，还有人们问，他弹空气吉他也是即兴的吗？全都是雷恩。全都是雷恩。这其中还有一件很有趣的事。所以通常当你在场景中有音乐时，他们其实不会在现场播放音乐。事实上，会是一个盛大的舞蹈场景或俱乐部场景，比如说你在拍一场婚礼。
They'll play a few seconds of the music so that you can get the beat and then they turn it off and you have to dance with no music, with no music and say your dialogue. And then they add the music later in editing. And that's so they can get your dialogue clean and so that they can cut between different takes. And it, you don't want this song in the background. Well, for this scene, they actually played the music on the boombox. And it made for a bit of a challenge in the editing room, but Greg felt like it provided so much to Rain's performance for him to have that music blaring. And also it's documentary. So you wouldn't have this like clean track of the music playing later. Although we did in Cafe
他们会播放几秒钟的音乐以便让你抓准节拍，然后他们会关掉音乐，你必须在没有音乐的情况下跳舞，在没有音乐的情况下说你的台词。然后他们会在后期制作中加入音乐。这主要是为了让你的对话保持干净，并且为了能够在不同的镜头之间进行剪辑。而且，你不会希望背景里有这首歌。好吧，对于这个场景，他们实际上在收音机里播放了音乐。这在剪辑室里带来了一些挑战，但格雷格觉得让雷恩伴随着震耳欲聋的音乐演出，为他的表演增色不少。而且这也是一部纪录片。所以你不会在事后听到这种干净的音乐轨道。虽然我们在《迪斯科咖啡馆》里，我们都在没有音乐的情况下跳舞。我记得那个。是的。在那个小迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司的桥段里。好吧。所以现在我们走进迈克尔的办公室，德怀特要开始阐述他为什么值得加薪。好的。这个场景发生在17分14秒左右。我必须告诉大家，我和雷恩·威尔逊拍过很多戏，关于他有一点你必须知道。这家伙酷爱道具。他太爱道具了伙计们。哦，天哪。所以当他举起那个文件夹时，我一点也不觉得意外。我有一种感觉，他和菲尔·谢伊就那个文件夹以及里面应该放什么讨论了很多。但雷恩真的很爱道具。好吧，你可以在18分12秒看到，说到道具，有一个标志，而且
Disco, we all have a dance to nothing. I remember that. Yeah. In the little Michael Scott paper company thing. All right. So now we move into Michael's office and Dwight is going to give his pitch for why he deserves a raise. Okay. This scene happens at around 17 minutes, 14 seconds. I just have to tell you guys, I did a lot of scenes with Rainn Wilson and here's something you have to know about him. The man loves a prop. He loves a prop guys. Oh my gosh. So it was no surprise to me when he held up that binder. I have a feeling him and Phil Shea talked a lot about that binder and what would go in it. But Rainn loves a prop. Well, you can see at 18 minutes, 12 seconds, speaking of props, there is a sign and it
在场景中从来没有被提及，因为它被删掉了。德怀特做了一个关于他自己的标志，他在上面拆解了自己的名字。我都记下来了。我也记了。好吧。说出来。我们轮流来。你来第一个。好吧，我们轮流来。好的。德怀特为他的名字写的首字母缩写。坚定的。工作狂。激烈的。好员工。努力工作的。极好的。你其实，我必须建议大家回去看这个的删减片段，因为有一整场戏他都在解释这个。首先，他在办公桌前向吉姆解释，然后他为吉姆的名字缩写提出了建议。他做了？是的。而且真的很棒。然后他们还展示了迈克尔办公室里的那个场景。所以这都是好东西。对我来说有趣的是，
never gets referred to in the scene because it got deleted. Dwight has made a sign of himself where he breaks down his name. I wrote it all down. I did too. Okay. Say it. Let's take turns. You do the first one. Well, let's go back and forth. Okay. Dwight's acronym for his name. Determined. Worker. Intense. Good worker. Hard worker. Terrific. You actually, I have to advise people to go back and watch the deleted scenes from this because there is a whole scene where he explains this. First, he explains it to Jim at their desks and then he makes suggestions for what Jim's acronym could be. He does? Yes. And it's really good. And then they also show that scene from Michael's office. So it's good stuff. It is interesting
在正片里从没被提及，因为它被删掉了。德怀特做了一个标牌，上面拆解了他名字的字母。我都记下来了。我也是。好吧。说吧。我们轮流来。你来第一个。好吧，我们来回说。好的。德怀特对自己名字的缩写解释。坚定的。工作狂。专注的。好员工。努力的。出色的。实际上，我得建议大家回去看看这一段的删减片段，因为里面有一整场戏他都在解释这个。首先，他在办公桌前向吉姆解释，然后他还给吉姆的名字缩写提出了建议。是吗？对。而且真的很棒。然后他们还播出了迈克尔办公室里的那个场景。所以这很精彩。这很有趣
to me that the two characters that were the most excited about their performance review were Dwight and Angela. I mean, Dwight put so much effort into his and then all Michael said was he's adequate. And then my character is like, I love to be judged. I think I hold up even to the most severe scrutiny. I'm so excited for this. And then he just slams the door in my face and says, you're satisfactory. Oh, I know. It's so sad. The two people who really wanted a performance review don't get it. So around 18 minutes, Jan is fed up. She's like, you know what? I need a minute. I'm going to step out. I'm going to collect my thoughts. And she goes into the hallway and we see the sign for the building. And
那两个对绩效考核最兴奋的角色是德怀特和安吉拉。我是说，德怀特为他的付出了那么大努力，结果迈克尔只说他算合格。然后我的角色就像，我喜欢被评判。我觉得我经得起最严格的审视。我太兴奋了。然后他直接把门摔在我脸上，说你是令人满意的。哦，我知道。太悲伤了。那两个真正想要绩效考核的人却没有得到。所以在18分钟左右，简受够了。她说，你知道吗？我需要冷静一下。我要出去一下。我要整理一下思绪。然后她走到走廊里，我们看到了大楼的招牌，而
here's what's in the building that we see. WB Jones Heating and Air. That's in office 110. Available 1400. It's available space. And then the number is 120. What? Then we have Dunder Mifflin, Inc. Sweet 200. And then we have Vance Refrigeration, Sweet 210. So here's something that's interesting. We haven't done that episode where we meet all the people in the business park yet, but they had to make that prop. Yeah. So I want to ask, that would actually be set deck. I want to ask Michael Gallenberg. Did he just randomly make up that JB? WB? WB. WB. And did he make up Vance Refrigeration? WB Jones. I mean, Vance Refrigeration is put there so far before we ever deal with it. I wonder like what that
我们看到大楼里有这些东西。WB Jones 暖通空调。那在110办公室。1400室可用。那是可用空间。然后号码是120。什么？然后我们有邓迪·米夫林公司，200号套房。然后我们有万斯制冷公司，210号套房。所以这里有一件有趣的事。我们还没有拍到我们在商业园区遇到所有人的那一集，但他们不得不制作那个道具。是的。所以我想问，那实际上是布景。我想问迈克尔·盖伦伯格。他是随便瞎编那个 JB 吗？WB。WB。而且他瞎编了万斯制冷吗？WB Jones。我的意思是，万斯制冷在我们真正接触到它之前很久就被放在那里了。我想知道那
was, who came up with that? Yeah, we need to, we need to talk to Michael about all of those little things because they will come to figure so prominently in upcoming episodes. Oh my gosh. Bob Vance. Bob Vance. Vance Refrigeration. Then we have the scene with Jim and Pam in the break room. Yes, they're talking about Michael and Jan. And Pam says, how do you come back from that? And Jim so clearly takes it to heart because he's thinking, how would they come back if him and Pam hooked up and it didn't work out? How would they come back? How would he come back from that? It's so clear to me that that's what he's thinking. And he's like, yeah, you know, I don't know how you do come back from that, especially
是什么，是谁想出来的？是的，我们需要，我们需要和迈克尔谈谈所有这些小细节，因为它们将在接下来的剧集中发挥非常重要的作用。哦，天哪。鲍勃·万斯。鲍勃·万斯。万斯制冷。然后我们看到吉姆和帕姆在休息室的戏。是的，他们在谈论迈克尔和简。帕姆说，你怎么能从那种事里缓过来呢？吉姆很明显把这话听到心里去了，因为他在想，如果他和帕姆有一腿但没有结果，他们会怎么缓过来？他会怎么缓过来？他怎么能从那种事里缓过来呢？这对我来说太明显了，他就是这么想的。他就像，是的，你知道的，我不知道你怎么能从那种事里缓过来，特别是
if you work together. And then Pam goes, no, I mean, how do you come back from hooking up with Michael? Right. And he's like, oh yeah, yeah, yeah, Michael. But you see the whole time I feel like Jim sort of went deep and I feel like Pam kind of stayed surface. Yeah, I don't think Pam's thinking any of that stuff at all. She's really thinking, Jan hooked up with Michael. Yeah, Michael. Yeah, she's not thinking office romances. But it's just a little moment for me that kind of broke my heart. And it's kind of like what Larry is talking about that at the heart, it's a romantic comedy, you know, and Jim is thinking about Pam. And so when he realizes Pam hasn't even clocked that, you know, that
如果你一起工作的话。然后帕姆说，不，我是说，你怎么能从和迈克尔有一腿这件事里缓过来？对。然后他就像，哦对，对，对，迈克尔。但你看到整个过程，我觉得吉姆有点走心了，而我觉得帕姆还停留在表面。是的，我觉得帕姆根本没想那些事。她真正想的是，简和迈克尔有一腿。是的，迈克尔。是的，她没有在想办公室恋情。但这对我来说只是一个小插曲，有点让我心碎。这有点像拉里所说的，核心其实是一个浪漫喜剧，你知道的，吉姆在想着帕姆。所以当他意识到帕姆甚至没有注意到这一点，你知道的，他在以一种她甚至没有想到的方式思考着他们。随后简说她要回纽约了，然后有一场大戏是迈克尔追她到电梯。哦，珍娜，在我们进入那场戏之前，我对背景里的某个东西只有一个小小的评论。是什么？在19分8秒，伙计们，当简离开大楼而迈克尔追出去时，你真的可以好好看一下邓迪·米夫林招牌。哦，是的。事情是这样的，你可能会以为那个招牌是用什么坚硬结实的东西做的，对吧？难道它不看起来像，是的，像塑料或者别的什么？是的，复合材料。那是泡沫板。是的，有时几乎
he's thinking about them in a way that she's not even thinking about in that moment. Jan then says she is heading back to New York and there's this big scene where Michael chases her to the elevator. Oh, Jenna, before we get into that scene, I just have one little comment about something in the background. What is it? At 19 minutes, eight seconds, you guys, as Jan is leaving the building and Michael's chasing after her, you really get a great look at the Dunder Mifflin sign. Oh, yeah. Here's the thing, you probably think that sign is like made of something hard and sturdy, right? Doesn't it look like, yeah, like plastic or something? Yeah, composite. It's foam board. Yeah, sometimes like almost
他以一种她当时甚至都没有想到的方式在考虑着他们。简随后说她要回纽约，接着有一场大戏，迈克尔一直追她到电梯口。哦，珍娜，在我们进入那个场景之前，我对背景里的某个东西只有一个小小的评论。是什么？在19分钟零8秒的时候，各位，当简离开大楼、迈克尔在后面追她时，你真的能把邓德米夫林的招牌看得很清楚。哦，对。事情是这样的，你可能觉得那个招牌是用某种坚硬结实的材料做的，对吧？它看起来不像吗，对，就像塑料什么的？对，复合材料。其实是泡沫板。对，有时甚至有点像
like a craft project. It's almost like a poster you would make for your kid's third grade project. I remember we would have scenes where we'd have to line up and come in and out of the office and we'd be stuck back there in that little corner off camera and you could just push on it. It was just like foam board. Well, I used to remember being worried for it because it did feel very precarious. Like if you your elbow might go right through it. I remember one time Oscar was leaning on it and I was like, Oscar, the D is getting like all like bent. Stop. Yeah. Anyway, I'm just saying that sign guys, you know, it's Hollywood smoke and mirrors. It's just foam board. You could have made it for your third grade project.
就像一个手工项目。这几乎就像一个你为你孩子的三年级项目制作的海报。我记得我们以前拍戏时得排队进出办公室，我们会卡在镜头拍不到的那个小角落里，你可以直接推它。它就像泡沫板一样。好吧，我以前记得为它担心，因为它确实感觉很不稳定。就像如果你的手肘可能会直接穿过去。我记得有一次奥斯卡靠在上面，我说，奥斯卡，那个“D”都被压弯了。住手。是的。无论如何，我只是想说那个招牌，伙计们，你知道的，那是好莱坞的烟幕弹。它只是泡沫板。你也可以为你三年级的项目做一个。
I love that tidbit. I think that's a good tidbit. It's a good tidbit. I would sometimes walk past it and just push on a letter. Angela, that's so like devious. I could know it felt funny. Was that like your character just getting out a little tension? I don't know. But sometimes I'd walk past it and go squeaky. So Jan gives this big speech at the elevator, which is amazing. It's amazing. Malora is amazing. Amazing. And it cuts back and forth between them at the elevator and all of us in the office. We had a fan question from Molly Smileyface. When Jan is leaving and her and Michael are arguing, could you guys actually hear it or did you just act like you could? We could hear them. We could hear them. They had a
我喜欢那个花絮。我觉得这是一个不错的小花絮。这是一个不错的小花絮。我有时会从它旁边走过，然后随手推一个字母。安吉拉，这也太狡猾了吧。我知道，感觉怪怪的。那是你的角色在释放一点紧张情绪吗？我不知道。但有时我会走过去，然后发出吱吱的声音。所以简在电梯旁发表了长篇大论，太棒了。太棒了。梅洛拉太棒了。太棒了。镜头在他们电梯旁和办公室里的我们之间来回切换。我们有一个来自莫莉笑脸的粉丝提问。当简要离开，她和迈克尔在争吵时，你们真的能听到吗，还是你们只是假装能听到？我们能听到。我们能听到。他们
camera on us and we could hear them. And it was as much fun to listen to as you would imagine in real life. It would be fun to listen to that. Oh yeah. We had a camera on us the whole time they did their scene. And so I think what people don't realize too is the space from reception to that elevator wasn't very far. No, it really wasn't. So we were in fairly close proximity. It just doesn't look like it the way we would always film. And also the walls aren't really real thick walls. Yeah. You can hear. Yeah. They're just very easily. Yeah. And also the elevator is obviously not a real elevator. It is a box with a door with like a guy with a pulley. With a cable. Yeah. He would like pull the
在拍摄我们，我们能听到。而且正如你在现实生活中能想象的那样，听他们吵架和听起来一样有趣。听那个一定很有趣。哦，是的。在他们拍那场戏的整个过程中，我们都有摄像机对着。所以我想人们也没有意识到，从前台到那个电梯的距离其实并不远。不，真的不远。所以我们靠得比较近。只是我们平时拍戏的方式让它看起来不像那么回事。而且墙也不是那种真正的厚墙。是的。你能听到。是的。非常容易听到。而且电梯显然也不是真正的电梯。那是一个带有门的箱子，有一个人用滑轮拉着。用缆绳。是的。他会把
doors open and shut. And he would have to try to time it to look real. But something I love in this scene is that the timing of Michael saying, so what you're saying is it had nothing to do with my looks. Like that that's his takeaway from that speech is that she doesn't find him unattractive. And she just goes. And then the door is closed. It was perfect. I mean, amazing. And then this is, you know, a little background tidbit that I love at 19 minutes, 14 seconds while Malora as Jan is having this speech, we see the door advance for refrigeration. There it is. There it is. That's where they are. They're right on the other side. So you can see that Phyllis and her fella weren't very far apart. They
门拉开和关上。而且他必须努力把握好时机，让它看起来真实。但在这场戏里我最喜欢的一点是，迈克尔说“所以你的意思是这和我的长相无关”的时机。就像那是他从那场演讲中得出的结论，即她并不觉得他没有吸引力。而她只是走了。然后门关上了。太完美了。我是说，太棒了。然后这是，你知道的，我喜欢的一个背景小花絮，在19分14秒，当梅洛拉饰演的简在发表这段演讲时，我们看到了万斯制冷的门。在那呢。在那呢。这就是他们所在的地方。他们就在正对面。所以你可以看到菲利斯和她的男朋友离得并不远。他们
weren't. I wonder where did they meet in the elevator? Maybe the elevator. Or did they know each other before? We'll have a lot of questions. We learn about that romance in the Christmas episode, which is coming up. All right. So here we go. We talked about cold opens. This episode has a tag tag, the little tidbit at the end. It's the next day. Where is Dwight? If you rewatch this, this is one long tracking shot, which is just a great shot. It's kind of amazing how we timed it out. You, you see everybody working and then we go to the window. You see Dwight down at the window getting out of his car. It's really terrific. The prank worked. He doesn't get to work until like noon or something. Yeah. He comes barreling
确实不远。我很好奇，他们是在电梯里认识的吗？也许是电梯。还是他们之前就认识？我们会有很多疑问。我们将在即将到来的圣诞节那一集中了解这段浪漫史。好吧。所以我们开始吧。我们讨论了冷开场。这一集有一个标签标签，也就是最后的那个小彩蛋。那是第二天。德怀特在哪里？如果你重温这一段，这是一个长镜头，这是一个很棒的镜头。我们对时间的把握真是太神奇了。你，你看到每个人都在工作，然后我们走到窗户前。你看到德怀特在楼下从他的车里出来。真的太精彩了。恶作剧成功了。他直到中午左右才来上班。是的。他气势汹汹地
out of his car, all frantic. And of course you see the really cute Jim and Pam that they do a little like actors bow to each other. They do. Like well done. Yes. Yes. And that is performance review. That's performance review. We would love to thank Larry Wilmore for coming on today and you guys for tuning in. And we will be back next week with email surveillance and guess who's going to be in the booth with us? Ken Jong. Yes. And Angela, this is going to be a big episode for you. Oh yeah. It is Dwight and Angela. Dwayne Angela is born officially. Bumpin' Birkenstocks. Woo. All right. We'll see you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher
从车里出来，非常慌乱。当然，你会看到非常可爱的吉姆和帕姆，他们互相做了一个类似演员谢幕的动作。他们确实做了。就像干得好。是的。是的。这就是绩效评估。这就是绩效评估。我们要感谢拉里·威尔莫尔今天做客节目，也感谢收听的各位。我们下周将带来《邮件监控》，猜猜谁会和我们一起在录音室里？肯·郑。是的。安吉拉，对你来说这将是一个重要的单集。哦，是的。是德怀特和安吉拉。德怀特和安吉拉正式诞生了。碰撞的勃肯鞋。呜。好的。我们到时见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由 Earwolf 制作，詹娜·费舍尔
and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Peefer. And our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Gratton. For ad-free versions of the show and our bonus episodes Candy Bag, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial of Stitcher Premium use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
和安吉拉·金西。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·皮费尔。我们的主题曲是克里德·格拉顿的《橡胶树》。要收听本节目的无广告版本和我们的福利节目《糖果袋》，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。要获得 Stitcher Premium 的一个月免费试用，请使用代码 Office。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。